Hey, good morning, everyone.
We invite you to take your
seats.  As a courtesy to the
presenters, we ask everyone to
mute their devices at this time.
Good morning.  And, welcome
back.
Everyone, good morning.  Will
you please welcome back to the
stage, dan
DPAN dan.
Thank you for getting here
bright and early in the morning.
We said things were starting a
half an hour early.  Welcome to
everyone on the livestream and
all the people who were watching
on our viewing parties.  One is
we do not have lightning talks
today.  Please, you know, try to
stay for both 20-minute
sessions, if you can.  Check the
schedule, one more time, to make
sure you don't miss your
favorite.
As you noticed, there was a
schedule change.  The D8 and R8
talk is not happening.
Mr. Wharton has a special
project and we congratulate him
on that.  Instead, we'll have
Trash Talk.
But, the exciting part, right
now, is we have an esteemed
group talking about foldable.
[Applause]
Good morning, everyone.  My
name is Adrian Roos.  I'm a
software engineer.
I'm Andrii and I work on
multi-display.
I'm Jisun, I'm engineering
director.
By now, I'm sure you've seen the
announcement that we're
partnering with Samsung and
we're diving deeper into what
that means, what we're doing to
support developers for foldable
devices.  Jisun is here to talk
more about what Samsung is
doing.  So, with that, I'm going
to hand it over to Jisun.
Thank you.  So, again, I'm Jisun
from Samsung Mobile and I'm
going to talk about the new form
factor device, which you
announced at the Samsung
Developer Conference.  Okay.
So, I will cover more
information about the device,
itself, and also, we'll talk
about the experience, the new
foldable device will bring to
the users.
We all know that the smartphone
has been providing new
experiences for the last 10
years.  And it actually changes
the way people think, act and
also communicate.  Additionally,
it also opened up a lot of new
opportunities for the
developers.  Now, we believe a
foldable phone is one of the
next game-changers, which will
provide a very unique experience
to the users and also new
opportunities for the developers
to drive innovations.
Okay.  So, now let's talk about
the first Samsung foldable
phone.  The first
Samsung foldable phone is
designed to be multi-display
with two screens and also
supports multi-activity window.
So, let's take a first look at
what the actual configuration on
the display actually looks like.
So, this is the main display,
when the device is unfolded.
The main display is large enough
to provide a very unique
experience.  The experience
becomes richer and more
immersive.  The experience was
hardly achievable, even from the
larger screen smartphones.
In addition to the experience
from a single larger screen, two
multi-tasking will become
available to utilize this larger
screen with up to three
multi-active windows.
When the phone is actually
folded, we still have very
useful and portable cover
display to use.  In this mode,
the experience is very similar
to your daily smartphone use,
but compared to the main
display, the experience is more
to be focused and handy and
quick interaction, to actually
leverage the small screen.
So, having said that, here are
some numbers that you may be
interested in.  This is the
specs and the dimensions of the
actual screens.  So, 4.5-inch
cover display provides 21:9HD
plus resolution and a
320DP.
7.3-inch main display 4.2 plus
resolution with the same 420DP
with 585DP is the smallest
width.  These are the numbers
you may need to know.
Now I will show you some
expected user experience with
some examples. So, comparing the
experience between the existing
smartphone and fold main
display, the foldable is
foldable and can locate larger
to the application and it
actually enables the contents,
on the screen, to be richer and
more detailed, as you can see
from the screen.
On the cover screen, when device
is folded, I said the experience
can be optimized to provide
quick and easy access and
interaction.  While the device
is fully-functional, like a
normal smartphone.
Access to the quick panel or
notification or call or
messaging is good to highlight
the cover display.  We know that
you may not want to unfold your
phone to take an incoming call.
While the cover display and main
display, each one provides its
own very unique experience.  It
is between them, not separate
nor disconnected.  Rather, the
user experience, between the
display, is very continuous and
connected seamlessly.
As an example, if you want to
search for the location of the
center from a map, you can do
that with your phone folded.
However, if you unfold your
phone, the application still
continues to run.  Even more,
unfolding the phone actually
provide more information with
more visual cues, like what's
nearby and what's the location
to the other point of interest.
Using the gallery app is
similar.  The app experience
continues between the folded
mode and also the unfolded mode.
Multi-active windows for
multi-tasking is also one of the
key features.  So, while
watching a YouTube video, if you
want to browse a website, you
can just
open up a browser and browse the
website while your video keeps
playing.
Moreover, if your friend sends
messages and the notification
pops up, it can grab the
notification and drag it to a
third window, like this, to
continue chatting and browsing,
while your video still keeps
playing.
So, we have this expected
experience with the new foldable
device, so now Adrian, from
Google, will talk about
developer guide and also some
Android support to make your
applications better-fit for the
foldables.
Thanks for sharing that,
Jisun.
[Applause]
So, let's talk a bit more
about how you can take advantage
of foldables in your apps and
kind of the guidelines we could
recommend to do so.  So, first
up is screen continuity.  It's
what we call the concept of
continuing what you're currently
doing after you fold or unfold
the device.  And, an example
here, we have -- you have a map.
You're looking at on a folded
device.  And, you would like to
see maybe a bit more about the
surroundings of the place you're
looking at.  So, as a user, you
unfold the phone and with the
continuous experience, we're
still looking at the same place,
your state is maintained and the
phone can take a bit more
advantage of the form factor.
And this is actually not really
a new thing in Android, right?
We've had to deal with similar
situations before, with things
like screen rotation or changing
-- changing screen sizes or --
sorry.  Changing window sizes in
multi-window.
So, why should you care about
continuity when you build your
app?  Well users unfold their
devices for a reason and usually
that's because they want to dive
deeper into the task they're
currently doing.  So, that
really works best when they are
not interrupted in their
experience when doing so and can
continue where they left off
before unfolding.
So, for a satisfying user
experience, it's really
important that this works well.
That seems great.  Now, how do
you actually pull this off?
Well, as I said, Android is
familiar with this and we've
built a system to deal with
that.  Folding and unfolding the
device will be treated as a
configuration change in the
screen size and screen layout
categories.  And, to support you
with that, the Android system,
by default, re-creates your
activities when a configuration
change happens.
This has the advantage of taking
care of any layout changes you
might want to make when taking
advantage of the new
configuration.  But it also
means that you, as the app, are
responsible for restoring the
state the user was in after that
activity's re-created.
To support with that, we have a
state facility and introducing a
new Jetpack library called
ViewModel to support you with
that.
Alternatively, you could also
decide to handle the
configuration change yourself by
just applying it and adjusting
your layout.  To do that, you
can declare that you can handle
the configuration change in your
manifest, but that means you'll
have to manually adjust the
screen size.
Make sure to correctly implement
multi-window and declare your
activity as resizable.
Now, next up, we're making some
changes to the lifecycle in
multi-window.  You can see the
current behavior on the left.
That is that only the activity
that the user last touched is in
the resumed state while all the
other are in the paused state.
That's a bit confusing to users
because it's not immediately
able to see why some are in a
less interactive state and it's
one more thing you have to keep
in mind, as a developer, when
you target multi-window.  We're
introducing multi-resume mode.
It's pretty simple, really.  All
the activities in multi-window
that are at the top and are
visible are all in the resume
state.
Now, Android Pie didn't ship
with this behavior originally
and so we're making this an
opt-in behavior in Android Pie.
It will only be applied with the
app developer ops in and the
device manufacturer actually
implements this feature
according to our spec.
But note that in future versions
of Android, we're expecting to
make this mandatory behavior.
So, let's say you have an app
and want to take advantage of
this simplified lifecycle, how
do you opt in?  Again, you add
one flag to your Android
manifest.  There's one caveat,
though, because there are
multiple activities that can be
resumed at the same time.  Be
really cautious around code that
stores the one resumed activity
because there might now be more
than one of those.  Be cautious
around libraries and frameworks
that might make the same
assumptions.
And with, that I'm going to hand
it over to Andrii, who is going
to talk about
multi-window/multi-display.
So, let's talk a bit more about
multi-screen devices.  A
an activity can be launched on a
display.  Let's see what it
actually means for your
activity.  First of all, when an
activity is on a non-default
display, the activity context is
different from non-visual
application context, also
available from broadcast
receivers and content providers.
The context of a visible entity
will be adjusted for the display
area where it is shown.  If you
use the same API to get the
current display and use a
different context type to ask
for it, you will get different
results.  The current display,
you can get, is from the
activity and the application
context will always give you the
default display.
Different context also mean
different resources and
configurations.  It will be
automatically updated for you.
All you need to do is request
them from the correct context.
When you want to adjust your UX,
you should be using an activity.
Keep in mind that the user may
move your activity from one
screen to another at any point.
In most cases, you can expect
this place to have different
sizes, densities and
resolutions.  This means the
activity that was muted will get
the configuration change.  If it
is declared to handle the
change, it will be notified with
the new config.  If not, it'll
be launched.
To deliver the best experience,
we encourage you to handle
configuration changes whenever
it's possible and if your app
needs to know what display, you
can find it on ondisplay.
What if you want to take
advantage of these additional
screens?  How do you use them?
The first step is
to get information about the
displays.
You can check their flags,
metrics and states. For example,
you can look for live screen to
provide media content or filter
out the displays that are
currently off.
Once you have determined what
display you want to use, you can
launch your activity there using
the activity options API,
available in Android I/O.  If
you want a new instance of an
activity, you may want to use
corresponding flags and use new
task for this launch.
Sometimes the system may
restrict activity launches to
some certain displays, for
example, private displays.  You
can expect this.
Remember that there are several
platforms that actually have
multi-display devices.  Phones
is one example we have covered
today.
Next, there is desktop mode.
When you connect your phone to a
larger screen for improved
productivity or entertainment.
Android apps running on Chrome
OS.  In both of these cases, the
apps are usually running in
free-form mode and the user
expects them to be freely and
smoothly resizable.
Last but not least is automotive
Android.  There may be many
screens in a car.  For example,
kids in the back seats may be
playing same or different games
while the driver is using
navigation.
For apps, in general, there
shouldn't be too many
differents.  To verify your app
behavior, on any Android device
running O or above, you can
create a simulated display and
launch your activity there.
At this moment, simulated
display does not handle touch.
We are working on improving this
and we are going to be adding
new developer tools.
With all this new and existing
platforms, you can choose to
optimize your app and build a
multi-screen experience.  You
can test your app and set
corresponding launch modes.
Don't forget that in this case,
multiple activities may be
focused.  Also consider using
the shared data and take
advantage of other Architecture
Components.
[Applause]
So, we've talked about what's
available today.  Let's look
more at what's going to be in
the future with foldables and
multi-display devices.  In the
short-term, for Android Pie,
we're working on developer
guidelines and we're going to
show you how to best-target
foldables and multi-display
devices.  We're also working on
a blog post that's going to go
live, which will have more
information about everything we
talked about.  And we're also
working with Samsung to release
an emulator where we can develop
and test your apps against the
configuration change behaviors
and the multi-resume behaviors
that their device is going to
have.
Looking a bit more into the
future, with future versions of
Android, we're implementing
support for foldables and
multi-display devices and as
part of this, we're also going
to improve the emulator, so it
will have support for simulating
all those foldable and
multi-display behaviors, as
Andrii also mentioned.
Finally, some pointers on where
you can find more information.
In the following days, we'll
have this blog post up.  There's
a Samsung developer site where
you will find more information
about Samsung's devices and
their guidelines and for testing
your apps, the Samsung emulator
will also be available on their
website some time in Q4.
Okay.  At this point, I would
also like to thank you for all
the amazing experiences you
developers are building for
Android and we're really excited
to see what you will do next and
what you will do next on this
next form factor of foldable
devices.  Thank you.
[Applause]
be in the Q&A area where you can
talk to us later, in the next
break.
All right.  I just wanted to
have a few minor things.  One is
that you noticed that we're
going to have these Q&A slides.
These have these QR codes and
those allow you to rate all of
the sessions here at the Android
Dev Summit.  Please let us know.
We did a lot of experimentation
with content this time.
Second thing is, I know we
didn't have the D8 and R8 talk,
but we have the engineering lead
out in the sandbox area.  If
you're interested in R8, please
go out and ask questions in the
sandbox area.  You can rate all
the sessions, all day long,
today, from the single QR code.
So, thank you very much.  Enjoy
the rest of your day.
Everyone, the next session, in
this room, will commence at
10:20 a.m.  Thank you.
Everyone, welcome back.  We
invite you to take your seats.
Our program is going to be under
way in three minutes.  As a
courtesy to our presenters,
please mute your devices.
Welcome, everyone.  Please be
seated.
[Applause]
Good morning.  I'm Chris.
And I'm Alan.
We're here to talk about
pixels.  We need to think about
the actual technologies.  There
are two prevailing technologies,
LCD.  The majority of devices
are screens, from the mid-level
to the
high-level.  And even in
platforms, they're moving to
that, as well.
LCD stands for liquid crystal
display.  They work with what
they call liquid crystals so
each pixel is made up of a color
channel.  They require a
backlite.  So, those liquid
crystals don't illuminate
themselves.  Now, most of the
power for an LCD display goes
into that backlite.  So, more
brightness is more power.
Olet displays are diodes, which
actually emit light themselves
so there's no need for a
backlight.  The good thing,
here, is that they allow a true
black.  So, with LCD, the way
you achieve black is by turning
all the crystals on so you can
never really get that dark
black.
Olets are different.  They don't
turn the pixel on and that's how
you get black.  That's where the
power is.
And the
power is powered by emitting
light.
Now, there's a number of
arrangements, you have R, G and
B.  So, let's more
straightforward
and mentally simple.  There's
more complex ones, like RGBR.
Each pixel only has two
channels.  It's a way of
expanding pixel size without
fitting as many LEDs in it.
In terms of power, more LEDs
equal more power usage.  We've
done stats over the last year or
two and the display tends to be
the biggest power user of your
device.  You see a chart, the
display, the more power it uses.
Everyone assumes this is the
case.  But the thing is, it's
actually quite linear.  Again,
kind of simple.
But then we start comparing oled
devices versus LCD screens and
it's the pixel versus that.  We
have a screenshot of maps in a
normal day mode and a night
mode.  The reason we use a
screenshot is because we didn't
want the differences been iOS or
Android to show it.
The actually amperage on night
and day is the same.  That
doesn't change because it's an
LCD screen.  But on the pixel
itself, because it's an oled
display, the power drops down by
63%.  The biggest power user on
your device, by using a dark
theme.
Going more into it, when you
have individual pixel colors --
so, we did a test where we
displayed one color on the
display.  And, the actual color,
itself, makes a difference in
power.  Blue is 24% more power
than, say, green or red.  And
then, another chart, which is
pretty much a summary of the
previous chart, but you can see
the black is using the least
amount of power.  It goes up and
up until we get white.  Because
white uses channels for every
one, it's full red, full green,
full blue, it requires the most
amount of color and guess which
color we've been pushing you
towards?  We changed from hollow
to this white theme and we shot
ourselves in the foot in terms
of power.
Let's look at Google apps over
the last year and the power
savings they've been able to
have.  Here
's YouTube, full brightness.
You save 43% of your battery
usage.  When you're playing a
video, it doesn't matter
anyways.
Now when it's paused, we save
even more, it's 60%.  My guess,
here, is because the overlay of
the video actually darkens the
video, you know, we use an even
more dark color so we save more
power.  This test, itself,
depends very much on the video
content.  If you have a video
that is fully white, you're not
going to save so much.
Gboard is a good example.  Users
can control this and save 20% of
your battery or the display use
of the battery, just by
switching to a dark theme.
Finally, on Maps, this is the
example of dark theme and where
it is really great because it
has the obvious benefits of the
battery.  You don't want Maps
being a really white theme when
you're driving at night.  So
dark theme, here, makes the app
more usable in a nighttime
setting.
And now Alan's going to talk.
All right.  So, how can we
embrace the dark side some
implement dark mode in our apps?
Going into dark theme.  Which
will not save us any battery
here, but it will on your
devices.  So, you may remember
Night Mode from the developer
preview of Android last year or
the year before that or the year
before that or the year before
that.  But, we released
Day/Night support in app
compats.  There's a great blog
article about it.  Our
recommended way to implement
Dark Mode in your app and
basically get it for free is
Day/Night.  You can get this
almost for free.  The stock
widgets will respond to the
changes in the device's Night
Mode and you can toggle between
Light and Dark mode.  This is
the demo from the AndroidX
checkout.  If you have it from
AOSP, you can take a look.
It's one line of code to switch
between whatever theme you're
using before and app compat.
You simply take whatever your
app theme is and have it
inherent from one of the
day/night themes.  Everything
might just work.
You can also apply a overlay
theme dynamically at runtime.
So if you want to have a pure
black oled themes, there are
some apps that already do this
or a pink Hello Kitty theme, you
can do it at runtime.  If you
want to learn more about overlay
themes, Chris and I talked about
those at I/O a few years ago.
This ensures any time a theme is
set, you will then immediately
overlay it with the black theme
or a Hello Kitty theme and any
views that get inflated will be
using that theme correctly.
All right.  Either, way, you're
going to want to structure your
app on theme attributes.  All of
the platform drawables
heavily-rely on theme attributes
to obtain their colors.  Color
foreground, color control
normal, color accent.  The thumb
-- sorry, the switch that you
can drag left and right, the
thing that sits under that is
colored light gray when it's
enabled.  And dark gray when
it's disabled.  The
implementation of that is just a
color selector, a color state
list that refers to the color
attribute, which is white under
a light theme.  Black on a dark
theme and an alpha.  We vary
that based on light and dark
themes.
There are no colors hard-coded
here.  We'll talk about this
more, later today, in a talk
with Nick Butcher about themes
and styles.
All right.  So, I mentioned
night mode showed up.  The
qualifier has been there since
SDK 8.  It was opened up for
general use in Android N, so the
ability to set the night
qualifier system-wide, there are
some apps that accidentally set
it.  Messenger has been doing
that recently, it has been
fixed.
It's a research qualifier
similar to portrait or
landscape.  You just create a
drawable/night and if you have
resources that are difficult to
extract theme colors out of, say
you have a welcome splash image
that is complicated, you can get
a dark version of that and it's
too complicated to put in a
vector drawable, you can drop it
in drawable night.  You'll pick
up that drawable automatically.
Same thing for colors, if there
are colors you want to switch,
say your accent color is darker,
you can extract that to a named
color resource, have one version
in colors, one version in values
night.
So, here's what the theme
implementation can look like.
If you want to switch your
parent theme based on night
qualifier, you define it once in
values and once in values night
and give it a different parent.
When it is non-night mode,
you'll pick up the light theme
when it's referenced under night
mode, when the night qualifier
is on, you'll pick up the night
theme.
We have the same color
referenced two different ways.
It will pick up black under
non-night mode.  It would pick
up white under night mode.
When you can do update your app,
maybe do a little bit of
restructuring.  Take a
screenshot of your app, invert
it, see how it looks.  Get a
sense of whether there are
images you'll need to have an
alturnive version of.  We have
avatars, maybe we want to change
the background colors a little
bit, so that may mean extracting
theme attributes or different
sets of PNGs to drop into
drawables night.
Next, you want to take a survey
of the usage of colors in your
layout XML and in your styles.
Set the parent of your theme to
be something dark,
theme.appcompat or
theme.material.  You'll want to
look and see if you're losing
contrast.  What you
you  see should look like it.
All the background colors and
foreground colors were
hard-coded to be light theme.
The one thing that wasn't
hard-coded -- and you can almost
see it here -- is the label for
first name, which is now
invisible because it's the only
thing that's correctly pulling
in the dark theme color
attributes.  So, this is going
to require a lot of work.
The hard part is doing that
work.  So, you'll want to
refactor your colors as much as
possible.  Take any hard-coded
layouts in your XMLs and move
them to named color resources.
You can base those on
values/values night.  If you
want to do more than one theme,
you'll want to extract those to
color attributes that have some
sort of meaning in your
application.  We have text color
primary, we have color ax sent,
we have color primary.  You
should be using those as much as
possible and certainly take
advantage of theme attributes
for specifying colors,
propagating those into your
lists and layouts.
You can convert your PNGs to
alpha masks and convert tinting.
You can wrap those where a bit
map.  We'll talk, again, a
little bit more about this at
the themes and styles talk
today.
Next, you move over and
get automatic switching in night
mode.  Here, we have the Twitter
app, which has a very obvious
affordance for switching between
day and night.  So, if you tap
this, it goes into dark mode.
There is a platform specified
dark node so you may have a
tristate.
You  you'll also want to test
that your application works when
Night Mode changes.  You can use
ABD, open your app, once you've
implemented the day/night theme,
toggle it into night yes.  It is
going to go through a full
on-display and re-creation and
preserve using data.
On pixel 3 devices running P,
night mode will switch and it
enters battery-saving mode.  You
can toggle it from developer
options and push might node to
be always on, always off or one
of the legacy things we have is
switching based upon time of
day.
You can learn more in the themes
and styles talk that I'll be
giving with Nick Butcher later
today.  If you want to learn
more about the lower-level
things, Chris and I gave a great
talk at Google I/O.  So that
covers anything you want to
know, but have been afraid to
ask about themes and styles.
We will be outside in the
Android Lounge to answer any of
your questions.
Thanks, everybody, for coming.
Please embrace the dark side.
[Applause]
Hello, welcome to Improving
Battery Life with Restrictions.
My name is Jingyu Shi, I'm a
partner developer.
Hi, I'm Amith Yamasani.
Today, we want to start with
this notification we've all
received, hopefully never around
this time of day.  Knowing that
our battery's running out can be
really frustraing and sometimes
scary depending on where we are
and what we're doing at this
time. These days, we rely so
much on our devices for
navigation, talking to our
friends and family, taking
pictures and even translate for
us when we are traveling in a
foreign country.
But all these cool features and
amazing apps that you built
cannot help the user if their
battery is dead.  So that's why
today, we're talking about how
we're going to improve battery,
with your help, hopefully.  And
this is what we're going to
cover.  First, we'll talk about
what's consuming power and how
we measure power consumption and
then we're going to go through
the power-saving features we've
introduced in feature years and
how your app will be affected by
these restrictions.
Next, I'll pass it over to Amith
to talk about what's consuming
power.
Hi.  Quickly walk through how
we actually estimate how an app
consumes power, how much power
it's consuming on the device.
These are the typical
components, hardware components
that are consuming power.  I've
highlighted the top consumers.
You got an earfull of display.
Running at high frequencies is
also pretty expensive and
transferring data over the cell
network is quite expensive, as
well.
So, when each device is
manufactured, the OEM has a
power profile.  What it contains
is the average current drawn by
various subsystems we want to
measure in realtime and, for
example, if you turn the screen
on, at minimum brightness, it
might be about 100.  If you
crank it up to full brightness,
let's say it add another 300.
So, we keep track of that in
realtime.  CPU has different
power consumptions.
At runtime, what we do is,
there's a subsystem called
battery stats.  It tracks what
each app is doing.  It measures
how long it's consuming each of
these resources, like, how much
CPU time, at what frequency, how
many data packets it's
transferring and so on and we
multiply with the power cost for
each of those and we get an
approximate estimate of how many
hours the particular app has
drained and we rank the apps,
presented to the user, so they
can see that in settings and
learn for themselves what is
really draining their battery.
So, let's talk about how the OS
is trying to help the user
extend their battery life.  But,
first, broadly-speaking, there
are two reasons why the app
runs, the user's launching it,
it's running in the foreground,
user's actively using the app.
As developers, that's something
you don't want them to not do,
but that's a whole different
topic about digital well-being
and trying to, you know, help
users control how much time they
spend on apps.
But one note I want to leave
here is there's a concept about
suspending apps and that's
something you might want to read
about and how that impacts your
app if the user suspends the app
for, let's say, the rest of the
day.
But we'll focus on how we try to
limit background activity from
an app.  An app can schedule
background work by using jobs or
alarms.  It can also register
for call-backs for external
triggers like push messages or
walking past a geofence.
Over the years, we've introduced
several features, in the OS, to
save battery.  First, in
Marshmallow, we introduced Doze.
It puts the device on a deep
sleep.  Let's say you left it on
your desk or nightstand, it
basically shuts down a lot of
the background activity so that
you can really extend your
battery life.
But this is not really how we
use our daily phones, right.
We're walking around with it.
So we came up with Doze on The
Go.  It
puts it to sleep lightly.  It's
not in front of you, you're not
using the screen so it can shut
down some of the background
work.
You're probably all familiar
with the Oreo
restrictions on background
services.  As of this month,
everyone needs to target Android
Oreo above.
But we'll focus more on what's
new in
P, Adaptive Battery, Battery
Saver.  Adaptive Battery is a
revolution of App Standby that
was introduced.  It put app in
two possible states, active or
non-active.  Adaptive Battery
extends this into four buckets.
Based on usage, we move it to
some other buckets.  For
instance, if you are Google I/O
and you install the I/O app, it
should go to the rare app
because you haven't been using
it.
So, how does the OS assign these
buckets to each app?  It starts
off when you're installing the
app in another bucket, it's not
shown here, it's really not that
relevant.  Once you launch the
app -- or every time you launch
the app or any kind of strong
interaction, like clicking on a
notification, the app goes the
app bucket and it stays there
for awhile, maybe in a few hours
it comes down and starts
applying restrictions.  And a
little later, most frequent and
then to rare and then we
uninstall your app.  I'm just
kidding.  We don't do that.
[Laughter]
If you're looking at a
notification, it's not a clear
indication that it's an active
usage of the app, so we put it
in a slightly-restricted state,
which is the working set.  What
is actually adaptive about this
is if the device has a machine
learning algorithm, it watches
your usage patterns, learns over
time and decides, okay, this app
is probably going to be used in
the next couple of hours, let me
put it in the active set and
maybe it can freshen up its
data.  And once it feels that
maybe the app is not going to be
used for awhile, it might move
it down in to one of the lower
buckets so this really
approves your ability of the
amount of apps it uses in the
background.
It's not your fault, you don't
know when the user's going to
launch you so we're trying to
help with that.
Restrictions is another feature.
We limit what the app can do in
the background.  It's mostly met
for apps you want to do in
theforegrounds.  There are two
ways the app can go into this
state.  The user might see, in
settings, that your app is
draining battery and decides to
manually restrict the app.  The
system is monitoring certain
criteria and if it feels it is
doing anything excessive, it
suggests to the user, do you
want to restrict this app
because it is draining your
battery in the background.
These are things we will improve
and OEMs are able to add
this.
The usual jobs, alarms,
full-ground service.  As far as
the user's concerned, it is a
background thing if you see
something happening with a
notification and it's doing work
in the background.  FCM, as of
January, will be restricted as
well.  So you won't get any
messages when your app is in the
rest state.  You don't get
location updates and one thing
that's unique about app
restrictions is even while the
device the chargeing, we don't
let you run in the background.
The reason is, this is not just
about saving battery, it's also
aboutabout annoyances and maybe
privacy concerns.
It's very similar to how
restrictions work.  Some of the
differences are foreground is
fine to run on Battery Saver.
There are no restrictions on
push notifications.
And, one thing that's new, in
Pie, is we turn off location
services completely, at least on
pixel devices, OEMs might not
choose to do that.
You can ask user stats, what is
your current standby bucket, at
this moment.  If you want to
debug something, you can also
get historical information about
your standby bucket changes. You
can check if you're
background-restricted right now
and maybe you want to tell the
user something about that.
Please don't nag the user.  If
they don't want you to run, they
don't want you to run.
And, you can also check if
Battery Saver's on, internally,
it's called power saver mode.
Thank you, Amith.
So, how is your app affected?
So, any time to the system, your
app will be one of these two
states.  It will be either in
the foreground or the
background.  And whenever your
app is considered to be in
foreground, all these
restrictions are lifted so you
can run whenever you need to.
When your app is in background
and the device is not charging
all of the Battery Saver
features that Amith just talked
about, any of them could be
enabled, which means your jobs,
alarms, network access and FCM
messages could be restricted.
Next, we have some really
beautiful diagrams, which will
show you how they are affected.
First let's do scheduled jobs.
Given all the constraints you
have on the job is satisfied
ified, these are the things that
will affect how it runs.  If it
goes, your job will defer to the
maintenance window.  If the user
decides to turn on Battery Saver
or app restrictions, meaning
restrict your app from that
battery setting, your job will
be deferred until the user opens
the app or the app is in the
foreground.
Your job could be deferred up to
24 hours, that's when your app
belongs to the rare bucket and
that's the worst case, which
means that even in the
worst-case, your job will still
get run every day.
So, similarly, for alarm manager
alarms, it will affect when your
alarms fire.  When it's in Doze,
your alarm will be deferred to
maintenance window.  If the user
turns on Battery Saver or
restrict your app, your alarm
will be deferred until your app
is in foreground.  And finally,
to the app standby bucket, your
alarm could be delayed up to two
hours if your app belongs to
that rare bucket.
If your use case requires that
exact time execution, then, for
example, if you want to remind a
user they need to take
medication or a TV program that
they subscribe to is about to
start, so for these use cases,
you can use this idol method so
your alarm will fire on time.
But you are using alarm manager
to wake up the device frequently
and imagine that every app is
doing that at a different time,
you're draining a lot of
battery.  That's why we have the
excessive wake-up on your vitals
page.  If you see it on vitals
pages, it's caused by alarm
manager, I would recommend you
think about maybe you migrate to
other APIs.
If you are sending push
notifications, you are probably
already using Firebase Cloud
Messaging.  When the device is
in Doze, your priority messages
will be deferred to the
maintenance window.
This is because high-priority
FC
FCM message, they're triggered
to send a notification to the
user.  If they turn on Battery
Saver, still your messages will
be delivered, as it is.
As Amith mentioned earlier, if
the user restricted your [no
audio]
audio].
They will apply on any app
that's running on Android
device, no matter which target
SDK you're targeting.  So, our
first advice to you is please
test your app.  We have ABD
command.  You can use to put all
your apps in this features to
see if your push notifications
are coming through.
Except for the high-priority FCM
restrictions, none of them are
knew.  If your app works well
under Doze, it's very likely
that you don't need to change
much to work with these
features.
Our second advice to you is
whenever you're running task in
the background, please keep in
mind to use this Lazy first
design principle.  Try to reduce
the work
KROUR  -- you're doing in the
background.  Can this wait until
my app is in the background?  If
you really need to run in the
background, try to defer that
work to a later time, say, when
device is plugged in or think
about that exact alarm.
Does it have to happen at that
exact time?  Can it wait?
Finally, try to do the work in
the background.  In Lollipop, we
introduced Job Scheduler, which
is a way for you to help the
system to intelligently batch
all the background work and this
year, we introduced WorkManager
in Jetpack, which makes running
background work better.  When it
is stable, it will be the
recommended way to do background
work.  So, with that in mind,
let's look at this upgraded view
of how you do things in the
background.
If
you need to execute a work that
is deferable locally,
WorkManager is your answer.  If
this work is triggered online,
then you would use an FCM
message with WorkManager.
Meaning you would want to use
FCM message to notify your app
there is work you need to do and
the in message handler, you
queue that work.  If your user
case doesn't fit with either of
these cases and you need to run
something at that exact time,
then you would want to use alarm
manager.
If this is something that the
user started, user is aware it
is happening and it must happen
immediately, you would use
foreground service.  But please,
whenever you are using this
foreground service, add that
notification because there's
nothing more frustrating about
seeing a bunch of notifications
and there's nothing I can do
about it.  Please add that
action in a notification for
user to stop this service and
notification is dismissed.
If you reach the end, I would
say go back to the top or you
should wait until your app is
inforegrounds.
So, we have a talk later today,
at 1:00 p.m., please go to that
to learn how to use WorkManager
to do background work.  We also
have a lot of best practices and
guidance, how you can help us to
help users save battery.  Please
visit to learn more.
And, we will be in the office
hours this afternoon for any
questions.  Thank you.
Thank you.
[Applause]
Everyone, the next session in
this room will begin in 10
minutes.  Thank you.
.
Welcome Android Dev Summit.
We'll be back at 1:00 p.m.
Cool.  Thanks for coming.
Welcome to Working with
WorkManager.  My name is Sumir
Kataria.
I'm Rahul Ravikumar.
We both work on Android
Architecture Components,
particularly, WorkManager.  Let
me grab my --
[Laughter]
All right.  We're going to give
you a state of the union about
WorkManager.  I want to give you
an abbreviated guide to
WorkManager.  So for those of
you who haven't used WorkManager
before, we want to give you the
basic APIs.  We're going to talk
about WorkManager, the things
you've asked and also the new
changes we've made since I/O.
So, let's talk about the state
of the union.  There have been
11 releases of WorkManager since
Google I/O and these are alpha
releases.  Today was the one --
was the 11th one.  And, beta's
coming soon so those of you who
watched the keynote yesterday
may have heard beta's coming
this month.  This was news to
us, too.
[Laughter]
So, we want to give you an
abbreviated guide to WorkManager
and what is it, for those of you
who are completely new to this?
It is
a library.  It wraps alarm
manager and those of you who
have used Job Scheduler will
find the concepts very familiar.
So, let's talk about work.
You've got a unit of background
work -- and we'll talk about how
we create it.  You've got it and
how does WorkManager execute
this work?  This is a graph that
might help you.  While your
process is up and running, we'll
feed to this executor that we
have.  You can customize this
thing.  But your process may be
killed and WorkManager is
guaranteed to do work.  It may
defer it, but it will do it when
the constraints are met.  If
you're API 23+, we used Job
Scheduler and before that we
used alarm manager.  Whenever
the signals are met, let's say
you put in a two-hour time delay
when you have network.  When all
those conditions are met, it
will still go to the same
executor.
All right.  Let's do a quick API
walkthrough.  So, the
fundamental unit of work, in
WorkManager, is a Worker.  Here,
I'm defining a calculation
Worker.  It extends the Worker
type.  The only thing you need
to do is extend do work.  Here,
I'm returning a success.  You
can also return a retry or a
fail.  I'm doing some expensive
calculation on the background
thread so you don't have to
worry about threading here
because WorkManager is
guaranteed to schedule your
work.
Here, I'm returning a result of
success synchronously.  How do
you make that work run?  So, for
that, you need to inqueue a work
request.  One is a one-time and
one is a periodic work request.
I'm using a one-time and
building it with the
calculation.  I'm telling it
initial delay.  This tells
WorkManager to only run the work
after two hours has passed since
the point of inqueue.  I'm
setting the charging constraint.
It is only eligible to run when
the device is connected to or
charger -- when the device is
actually charging.
I'll talk about tags in more
detail and I'm calling .build.
Now I need to do is call get-
instance and get the work.  And
it -- if you want to keep track
of what state your work is in,
you want to call get work info
by LiveData.  This returns a
LiveData of a work info.  That
is the state of your work and
LiveData here is a lifecycle of
observable.  So once you attach
it to a LiveData owner, once
you inqueue the work, once the
constraints are met, it'll go
into running and then finally,
it will go into succeeded state.
Remember the tag we added when
we built the one-time work
request, you can get it with
data.  You associate it with a
work request and there can be
one or many.  You can assign the
same tag to multiple things.  It
is by tag, LiveData.  LiveData
again.  A list of work info.
And again, I can do the same
things I did in the previous
slide.
So, one of the coolest features
of WorkManager is the ability to
chain work.  So, that helps you
define a graph of work and here,
I'm asking WorkManager to begin
with A, B and C and they're work
requests.  D and E are only
eligible to run once A, B and C
are done.  I'm asking
WorkManager to run A, B and C to
run in parallel.  And, finally,
I'm calling on this again.  FGNH
will only run once all the
proceeding runs are done.  Don't
forget to call
inqueue.
Returns are work continuation.
The work continuation is a node
in your graph.  This lends to a
very fluent API.  Every time you
call it, it calls a new instance
of another continuation.
Finally, don't forget to call
inqueue.  When you chain work,
the outputs of the parent work
request become inputs to your
descending work request or your
children.  This helps you manage
and send state from parent work
to the descendant work.
Now, finally, there's
WorkManager that also exposes
the API to cancel.  If you want
to do that, you can cancel work
by ID and every work request has
a unique ID.  Here, we are
canceling work by that ID and
you can also cancel work by tag.
So, those are the two APIs.
And, that's it.
And I want to point out that
all the things -- all the APIs
we've been showing are for alpha
11.  You may notice some slight
changes for those of you who
have been using this API before.
But everything is live today.
So, let's talk about how to get
the most out of WorkManager.  It
includes, how do I do a certain
type of task?  And the biggest
one that we get a question about
is threading.  How does
threading work in WorkManager?
So, we talked about a work
request, Rahul just mentioned
that.  You inqueue it.  We have
an internal task executor.  It
is a single-threaded executor.
The inqueue goes to that.  Every
app that the uses WorkManager
has a WorkManager database.
This is the source of truth.
This is where we keep track of
your inputs, outputs, dependency
chains.  After it's been
inqueued, sometime later, your
constraints have been met.  If
you have no constraints, it runs
right away.  If there are
constraints, the OS will tell
you.  Same task executor using a
Worker factory to create a
Worker.  It's a factory for
Workers and you can make your
own.  You can customize and do
things with it.
After the Worker's created, we
execute it on an executor.  This
is actually a thing you can
customize.  We'll talk more
about that, later, as well.
What if you don't want to
execute something on that
executor?  What if you're using
RxJava or Coroutine?  What if
you have your own solution you
want to use to run things in the
background?  This was a request
that came up quite a lot when we
first released WorkManager.
So, to do this, we want to
provide you an API to let you do
work, on your own, and just tell
us when it's done.  You want to
do async when you're done.  We
split it out the Guava team has
worked on this so you don't need
a full dependency for this.
It's literally one or two
classes now.  It's a feature
that can have one or more
listeners and those listeners
can be envoked on a spec feed
executor.
So using
this, we made listenable worker.
You need to override start work.
You give us a listable feature.
You do whatever work you want
and when you're done, set the
result on the feature and we'll
be able to listen to it and
react to it.
So the actual threading model,
in WorkManager, it goes to the
task executor, which uses the
Worker factory to create a
listen Worker.  We call start
work on it and we attach a
listener so we can listen to
whenever you're done.  The
Worker class is a simple
listenable worker.  We have the
do work method we talked about.
We override the start work for
you.  We create a feature.  On
the background executor, we
execute the work.  And we, of
course, return the feature.
So, now we have two classes,
Worker and listenable Workers.
Workers are a simpler class.  A
class that runs synchronously
and on a background thread.
Listenable runs runs
asynchronously on an unspecified
background thread.  You're
expected to do what you're
finishing there.
You may to return a listenable
feature.  If you have access to
Guava, you have access to
listeners.  If you don't, it is
a light-weight implementation we
provide in AndroidX concurrent
features.
One of the things that a lot of
people are trying -- and doing
incorrectly with work Workers is
they're trying to do locations.
If you listen to the Kotlin
suspenders talk, they talked
about it.  Remember that a
Worker class is synchronous.  If
you attach a call-back but
return success, your work is
already completed.  It's not
going to work the way you think
it is.
So, first thing we do here,
we're using a listener Worker,
this is the feature we'll return
and do our bookkeeping on.  In
the start work method, we'll
check to see if we have
permissions.  If we don't, we'll
set a failure on the feature.
Otherwise, what we'll do is
we'll get that provider's last
location.  This is like a
feature in GMS core or Google
Pay Services world.  And then we
return to feature.  That is the
high-level start work.
In the get location method,
we'll use that task and add a
listener to it.  If the task is
successful, we'll pass that back
with a success status.
Otherwise, we'll set an
exception.  We have addressed
the three cases where we want to
have a successful or an
unsuccessful task or if we don't
have permissions and WorkManager
will attach that listener, it'll
listen to the success and
failure of the task and do the
bookkeeping as necessary.
All right.
Let's talk about operations.
Sumir mentioned WorkManager uses
database as a source of truth.
When you inqueue or do work, we
have to do some
bookkeeping.
These are a database and we have
to do them on a background
thread.  As a result, they're
asynchronous.  What if you
wanted to do something after the
inqueue happened or the cancel
happened?  You want to make sure
they completed before you want
to do more stuff?  We've
introduced a new API.  Inqueue
and cancel have Operations.
Operation is a very simple
interface.  It has two methods.
A get state API, which returns a
LiveData.  If you attach an
observer, you will asea it
transitions from an in-progress
to a success or failure.  The
other one returns the feature
type.  Remember this API will
only return the terminal state
of the operation.  If you're
attaching a listener, you will
get a success or failed and what
the exception is and telling you
why the failure happened.
Another question a lot of
people have is, when is work
stopped, what happens when you
stop work on behalf of
WorkManager?  So, there's three
cases when work is stopped.  The
first is very simple, your
constraints are no longer met.
You said I neat a network to do
this upload task but your
network got lost.  A second case
is that the OS
pre-emted your work.  The third
reason is you canceled your work
somewhere else in your app.  How
do we stop work?  There's a
method listener Worker
on-stopped.  You override this
and you get your stop signal.
We cancel that feature so you
can add your own listener and
look for that.
So, this is your -- when one of
these two things happen for you,
this is your signal to be a good
citizen and clean up because
after this is called, the
process may be killed by the OS.
So, if the OS woke up your app's
process just to run this work,
it could actually kill it when
it decides that the work should
stop and if you happen to return
something after this signal,
say, you returned a success, we
ignored it because as far as
we're concerned, your work has
been stopped.
You can also pull from stoppages
in your Worker so you can call
the isstopped method.  That will
tell you whether you've been
signaled for stopping.  So,
let's look at how you can be a
good citizen and clean up.
Let's say we're parsing a file
asynchronously and you're doing
it in a Worker.  You've got this
input stream so you're reading a
file.  In start work, you say
parse file.  This is doing
something asynchronously and you
return to feature.  Here's parse
file.  You've got some executor,
whatever, a Coroutine, you're
asynchronously doing that.
You're opening a file, you're
reading each byte out of the
file, doing something with that
byte and when you're done, you
set a success because you're
done and you have the necessary
tricatch finally after that so
you can clean up after youself.
So, how do we handle when your
work gets stopped while this is
executing?  Let's say we want to
finish what we're doing, we
could easily close that input
file stream.  Okay.  So, what
happens now?  You've done that.
Let's go back to the code.
Well, if you're in the middle of
that read loop and you close a
file, it throws an exception.
The next time you try to read
something, fortunately, you're
already handling that exception
there.  There's one more case
you forgot about here which is,
what if the on-stop happens
before you open the file?
You're not looking for that
because it never got that signal
and you'll read that file
because it opened before you
tried to close it.  You'll do
all this work and how you fix it
is use that is-stop method.
This is a good example of how
you would honor the OS's signal
to you that you should stop and
be a good citizen.
So every time you inqueue a
method or every time you inqueue
a work request, it goes through
several transitions.  Let's look
at life of a one-time work
request.  It can be blocked, if
it's blocked on another request
or
inqueued.  Once it is met, it
goes into running.  Once --
depending on the result you
return, we'll take it to one of
the terminal states.  If the
Worker returns success, then
it's -- we'll terminate it with
a succeeded state.  If it
returns a failure, then we'll
mark it as a failure.  At any
point in time, while the Worker
was in a non-terminating state,
if you actually retry, then
we'll apply the back-off policy
and retry.  So the Worker will
go back to the inqueued state.
If you have a non-terminating
state and you call cancel, it'll
end up in cancel.
Now let's look at periodic work.
It's almost the same.  Because
it can be chained, there's no
blocked state.  It all ends up
in the inqueue state.  So,
whether you succeed or you
retry, it'll go back into the
inqueued state.  This might seem
confusing.  If you succeed, it
is done.  We'll wait for the
next interval.  If you fail and
ask us to retry, we'll apply the
appropriate back-off policy.
We'll tell you this is the
second time you're trying to run
it for that last period.
And, if you mark your work as
failed, then we'll transition it
to the fail state.  At that
point, your periodic work won't
run again.  When it's in a
non-terminal state and you
cancel it, we'll mark it as
canceled.
Let's apply that to life of a
chain.  Here is the parent of
all Workers.  So, when you
inqueue this chain of work,
all descendants are blocked now.
Constraints are met and it goes
into running state.  Once it is
done, let's assume you succeeded
so it unlocks B and C now and
they go into running and for the
sake of the argument, let's
assume that B succeeds and C
fails.  B unlocks D so D goes
into the inqueued state.  Notice
what happens to E, F, and G,
they all failed.  If a unit
gets canceled, all of its
descendants are also marked
canceled.
So I'm going to talk about
unique work and let's start with
a little question here.  What's
wrong with this code?  You've
got an application object in the
on-create.  The problem here --
and I've seen this in a few bugs
-- is that this inqueues
periodic work every time your
app process starts.  That's
probably not what you're trying
to do.  You're trying to set up
a sync here.  If you call this
code every time the app starts,
every time you've got another
thing that's syncing your code,
you really only want one of
them.  So unique
work lets you -- if you insert
the same key into a database
again, do you want to overwrite
and ignore what you're trying to
do?
That's what unique work does,
it's a conflict policy for
WorkManager.  Here's the syntax.
Unique is that name, that key.
Something that uniquely
identifies that chain of work.
Policy is the existing work
policy or the conflict policies
and then you obviously have your
requests.
So, the existing work policies,
there's three of them.  The
first one is keep.  If you have
things in blocked, running or
inqueuedinqueued, it will keep
them.  If the work is finished
or not sent, it will inqueue
what you sent.  The next one is
replace.
It always replaces the work
request in the database.  If
your work is running, it'll get
stopped as I described a few
minutes earlier.  It cancels the
old work and it stops it.  A
pend is a special one.  It
appends to that chain of work.
This is useful if you're trying
to do something, in order, for
example, you're trying to build
a messagng app and you're
sending messages in order, you
may have a unique chain of work
for sending messages and you
want to append new messages at
the end of it so it's basically
creating a tree for you.
Sumir mentioned that one of his
previous slides on how you can
customize WorkManager, so, let's
look at all the things you can
do.  You can actually specify a
worker factory that can be used
to use your Workers.
This is useful in the context of
-- if you're using Dagger and
you want to inject something,
this is a good place to do that.
You can specify the default
executor that you want all
WorkerWorkers to use.  You can
specify the Login if you want to
distinguish between a build and
release build and log more
information to diagnose your
problems and do Job Scheduler
parameters, like number of jobs
you want us to send to Job
Scheduler, the IDs you want us
to know in case you're already
using Job Scheduler before.
If you want to customize
WorkManager, then you have to
disable the default and add this
entry to your man
ifest.  So now that you've
disabled it, you need to
actually create a new instance
of configuration.
Here, I'm using the
configuration building and
overwriting it.  I can call it
to initialize.
So, make sure you do this in
your application on-create.
Because the system -- the
operating system can actually
envoke job sources on your
behalf.  WorkManager needs to be
initialized.
Finally, the last thing we
want to talk about, before we
wrap-up, is some tips for all
library developers out there.
If you're using WorkManager in
your library, you have some
special use cases we want to
think about.  So the general
advice we give is because
WorkManager's a single and the
application initializes it, as
Rahul just showed you, you're
not really in control of what's
there.  The default Worker
factory creates Workers and
listenlistenable Workers.  If
you need a particular dependency
injection or anything else of
that sort, you'll have to have a
contract with the app.
Silo your work with tags.  Rahul
showed you how to tag your work.
If you silo all your work, put
your prefix or your package name
or library name in your tags,
you can easily identify all the
work that's yours.  You don't
have to worry about other people
-- other people's work.
You can get your work and
operate on that.  Finally, we do
provide the ability for apps to
wipe away all work.  This is
generally for privacy reasons.
It's for that sort of critical
use case where you have to wipe
user data, for some reason.
So, as a library developer, how
do you find out if your work's
been gone from under you.  Look
at get last cancel all time --
sorry, it's very confusing.
Okay.  Next steps.  So, get
WorkManager if you haven't
already.  For those of you who
have, thank you very much.
We're up to alpha 11, so there's
three general categories of
artifacts, there's one and KPX
and testing support as well.
These are some helpful links.
Schedule task with WorkManager
is the developer.Android.com.
There's the YouTube -- on
YouTube, there's the Google I/O
2018 talks which talks about the
basics. Some of those APIs have
changed a little bit, but it's
still broadly a good thing to
read -- or to listen to.
And, also, please file your
feedback at our publish issue
tracker.  Beta is coming, we
were told yesterday morning. We
have to get back to work.
[Laughter]
Thanks a lot.  Please visit all
the Jetpack libraries on the web
and we'll be outside for any
questions you might have.
Thanks.
[Applause]
Everyone, the next session, in
this room, will begin at 1:55
p.m.  Thank you.
[Applause]
Hi, everyone.  Thank you for
joining us for Best Practices
for Themes and Styles.
And I'm Alan Viverette.
We will take about designing
themes and styles for your
appplication.  The way that
designers create mocks.  Here's
the latest iteration of the
Material Design theme pallet.
If you're not using if for
Android yet, you might recognize
primary from the Material
Theming in the platform.  It is
like color primary dark.  And,
when you get a mock from I
designer, you may doing a mental
mapping, this is going to be my
darker color, this is going to
be my primary color.  It's
important to make sure your
designers understands there are
canonical atattributes.  It can
be helpful to push back a little
bit and say, let's call this the
primary variance or primary
color and it's great that we all
of these pre-designed theme
colors with meaningful names and
meaningful contrast ratios that
have to exist between foreground
and background.
Occasionally, you will get a
brand-new color that doesn't
exist anywhere and finding a
name for this may be difficult.
Here we have a purple color
that's lighter than our primary
variance and it has contrast
against while so we're going to
be displaying white text on top
of it.  If we want to come up
with a name for this, we should
find something that can
generalize but is
self-capturing.  If we decide we
had a purple theme, now we need
a blue theme, we can reuse the
name of the color and reuse
those constraints.
So, what are we going to call
that?  Well, over in the pallet,
we have these on color.
On-primary means this is a
foreground color displayed on a
primary background and ensure
it's going to meet accessibility
ratios. You'll be able to read
the foreground text color
against the background.  We have
secondary, if we have something
on the blue color, it would be
white.  We can generate a new
name for the lighter color.
We're going to use on-primary.
That determines the foreground
color protection.  For
background color protection, we
want to make sure it contrasts
with primary.  We can call it
primary light, which seems
incredibly straightforward and
it is.  So, you can tell your
designer, every time we're
talking about this lighter
version of our primary color,
let's refer to it as primary
light and it'll have these
constraints.
If your designer decides we want
it to be blue instead of purple,
we can continue to use the same
constraints and use our
semantically-designed color
theme.  Similarly, we provide
common patterns for text
appearance.  We have headline,
overline, body.  These are
names from where they are going
to be used.  That determines the
pixel size, the weight and the
color.
On the right, we see what that
map to.  In this case, headline
is going to be roboto.  However,
if we decided we wanted to use,
let's say, comic sans, we
wouldn't have to go through and
create a new style everywhere in
our application because we do
have these names that imply how
they're used.
Use meaningful name when you're
extracting from your mocks.
Learn the Material Design
attributes. They are at
material.io.  Use this as a
commoncommon language when
you're looking at mocks or
looking at something new that
has a random gray color in it.
Make sure it has a name you can
use.  If you are implementing
dark mode, if you attended that
talk earlier today, you know
this gray needs to turn into a
light white because it needs
contrast against a certain text
color or background color.
Use meaningful attribute names.
They should be more or less
self-documenting.  Something
like primary light has more
constraints than it looks like
primary color.  Go ahead and
document these somewhere.  Start
an internal site you share with
your designers to make sure
you're always using a common
language when talking about the
components, the colors, the
reusable texts.  That's a good
starting place on how to name
them and how to talk about them.
When you get a mock that says,
this is the hex color
4836Ef, push back on that and
say, this isn't a hex color.  It
has meaning and we need to be
able to smoothly-transition from
this hex color to a hex color
with similar constraints.
So, now Nick is going to talk a
little bit more about what this
means in implementation.
Thank you.  Right.  So, we
talked a lot about
supporting different
semantically-named values.  It
can be implemented as theme
attributes.  What happens if
your design changes and all of a
sudden, instead of a purple
theme, you have a blue theme.
These semantic names protect you
and it's more wide-spread than
you might realize.  So, if you
want to have areas which can
support these kind of theming,
there are different ways you can
achieve this.  One way might be,
define different styles.  I'm
going to set up a style and call
that style 1 and then I want to
to look different so I'll give
it style 2.  The problem with
this approach is there's going
to be a lot of duplication and
there's 2 places for you to
maintain or bug fix or refactor.
Using the semantical pointers to
describe what it should look
like or a theme attribute
protects you against this.  It
might be more work to establish
this language and set up your
styles to refer back to theme
attributes, what it does is it
ends up with a single place, a
single style, that will refer
back to the theme attributes
defined for a given theme.
And the benefits of this is
it's going to duplicate the
style.
And also localizes the
modeifications.  So that means
it you need to change an
attribute, you go to that one
place where it's defined rather
than have to track it down where
it's leaked out.
It also has the benefit, I
think, of consolidation.  How
many times have you opened your
colors XML files and found 50
shades of similarly-looking
colors and you see a mock and
you say, okay, I'll just create
another color resource.  It
protects you against this.  You
want to condense it down to this
small pallet.  You have a nice
look and feel.
Basically, this approach really,
really helps you with the
maintainability of your app.  I
urge you to prefer theme
attributes where possible.  If
you write code like the top
line, the text color should be
this color resource, think of it
as a code smell.  Is this
layout, is there a chance this
might appear in a different
theme?  Could it be included in
a different area of the
application?  If so, should I be
looking at the bottom form,
looking at the question mark
syntax, which is how you refer
to these theme attributes?
So, we talked about the
importance of the semantical
parts.  You can set a theme
directly on an activity and
these are using components,
which is a doc theme or maybe
you're using a night mode.  So,
this is a theme which will
change between dark and light
depending on the time of day.
What happens if you have a
screen like this, this is a
Google I/O app.  Most of these
list items are the same but the
designed called for some to be
light on dark and some dark on
light.  You can do separate
layouts or separating text
colors.  Both of those basically
either leak out the information
beyond where you want it to lead
to an explosion of more
maintenance.  Instead, what you
probably want to do is look at
applying themes at the view
level rather than at the whole
activity level.  The attribute
theme was added in API 21.  So,
in this, you can set a theme on
a view or a view group and apply
a different theme to a
subsection of your view hiarkry.
So, in these example, you might
say you have a light theme and
apply a dark version of it, or
vice versa.  You can do the same
thing in code by using the
wrapper.  You take the existing
theme and it overlays a style on
top of it.
It is overlaid.  That means that
you have an existing theme and
any values from the theme you
set on top of are going to be
applied on top so you need to be
a little bit conscious of this
fact.  Either you don't want to
overlay a theme which supplies
too many values.  If I was using
material component
s light and then doc, you might
overwrite too much.  You want to
make sure the theme you're
overwriting expresses the theme
you need.
You might want to take a look at
the theme overlays just to theme
the attributes you want such
that when it's overlaid, you get
the resulting combination of
themes.
While the context theme wrapper
approach looks close to dynamic
theming, it's not.  You have to
apply a theme which you've
defined at compile time.  You
can't use this to take color
values and create a dynamic
theme.  This is ahead of time
thinking.
So, before you start setting a
bunch of theme attributes, it's
important to understand how
they're applied through the
platform.  We're going to do a
whirlwind tour that occur on
screen and your application
themes.  At any point in your
application, it's good to have a
background understanding that
you can point to something on
the screen and understand the
layer direction and theme
attributes and styles applied to
render it this way on screen.
If we want to set this color for
a single button, how would we do
that?  Well, let's dive into the
way that this gets resolved at
runtime.  We have button in XML.
If you watch the demystifying
themes and styles talk, you have
a complete understanding of how
this works.  If you haven't
watched that, go watch it.  The
button style that you see here
is pulled from the theme -- the
theme of the context in which
the button is inflated.  So,
relevant button-style attribute
here at the bottom of the
screen.
Next, where is that button style
designed?  It is on the material
theme there is widget.material
button.  Where do we find the
definition?  Over in styles
material.  So, we can see here,
the background is this button
default drawable.  Right below
that bordered ink button style,
we have another style.  We
realize it's going to be a
little bit closer because it
provides a color in the button.
So, let's dive into the
background that's used, there,
to see what gets pulled from our
theme.
In the buttoncolor.XML, it
matches up with the drawable
names so there's an easy chain
you can follow.  We have a
shape, it's a rectangle, it is
colored with a tint, which is
our button-colored background
material.  This gets applied to
the white color of the shape so
it's got a solid white color
here.  Let's dig into the tint.
It is our color accent.  It is
named buttoncoloredmaterialXML.
A very clear line of
indirection.  So, where does
this color accent from come?
It's going to come from whatever
exists in our application theme.
That inherits from material and
it will be the default teal.
So here are all the levels of
indirection we've looked at.
Some of the important ones are
if we want to change the style
for all buttons that get
inflated, that's our button
style theme.  The button style
that we're getting by default is
widget.materialbutton.  We can
change that to button.colored if
we wanted color buttons
everywhere.  We can also change
our color accent.  If we set
that in our theme, that gets
used everywhere.  We'll see that
color everywhere.
But what we want to do is one
button.  So, what would happen
if we set
bet  button on our activity?  We
could see it everywhere.  What
about in XML?
How can we fix that?  Well, what
if we set color accents on our
activity theme, now we're
getting that blue button, but
we're also getting blue switches
and everything else.  If you do
a search over XML files, you'll
see it in a lot of places. We
could try setting it in
layoutXML.  This does absolutely
nothing because it's a theme
attribute and you shouldn't try
to set it in Layout KWM
XML.
We'll create a theme XML and
apply that to the button and
we'll get what we wanted.
So, back to Nick for more
implementation.
Cheers.
So, I said you should prefer
theme attributes where you can.
But to do so, you kind of need
to know what is out there, what
exists.  Honestly, I don't have
a great answer for you, other
than looking through the file --
this is from the Android
platform or from appcompat or
material components.  They're
not that long and you can see
what's available.  You can look
at themes.material and see which
theme attributes they set and as
such, you are able to reference
or overwrite yourselves.
One note is that you might see
that some theme attributes are
double-defined.  The platform
defines an Android color control
highlight and then appcompat
defines its own.  So, which do
you use?  The answer is if there
is one defined in the appcompat,
prefer that because it will set
the platform one for you and be
available for backwards
compatibility.
You can refer to these in code,
using something like this and
uses KTX to make it more
convenient.
So, so far, we've talked about
using platform theme attributes,
and you absolutely should.  But
you can also create your own.
Let's walk through an example.
We have two screens, which
display very similar layouts.  A
list of schedule and speaker
details.  They only differ in
the how far with the space on
the space and the key line we
want to align it to.  You need
to leave room for the sticky
header time things.  To
accomplish this, we defined our
own theme attribute.  This is
called sessionless keyline.  In
the different activity themes,
we can provide different
dimension values for that
keyline.
And then RGS we just have to
have a single layout, which
references that -- that theme
attribute using the question
mark syntax to vary it without
having to maintain it, et
cetera.
Another place that theming comes
into handy is drawables.  We
looked at the platform button
from API 21 onwards, all
drawable support tint and tint
modes.  You can also do this in
vectors where they support theme
attributes for tints, as well as
for fills and strokes.  So you
can use this not just in 21, but
in the backwards compatibility
library as well.  If you need
the backwards compatibility, you
can use backwards.
There is an override which lets
you set a tint list to be
applied, which is something
we've learned to be extremely
handy.  It provides different
tints and all colors for
different states.  This is taken
from text primary.  One of the
things I love about colors like
this is some of the improvements
that arrived in Marshmallow 23,
which allowed you to separate
out the color and alpha
component.  This protects you
against the explosion of 20
different capacities of black.
Actually separating out the --
kind of the color information
from the alpha information
allows you to define more
specifically what you want.
Here, it was saying it's a light
screen and the foreground will
be ground.  You can say the text
will be black and have alphas.
So you don't have to define all
the combinations, you define the
semantically-named things.  And
then they get combined by the
color state lists.
I've cheated here and changed
the Android alpha to app alpha
because appcompat back ports
this to added color state list,
but it requires you to use App
Alpha.
The alpha channel of the color
and the alpha are combined.
Don't do this.  If you specify
-- this is a 50% white text if
you don't speak heck and a 50%
alpha.  You'll end up with 20%
alpha white.  You want to refer
to colors with full alphas.
Like I said, appcompat has this
and use resources to get the
backwards compatible behavior.
So, overall, if you apply this
theming, you can get a state
like this.  So, on the left,
these look quite similar.  On
the left, we have the Google
I/O.  And to retheme it, to fit
in with the look and feel with
this conference, rather than
I/O, this is the diffance.  We
had to change the
semantically-named colors.  It
ripples outwards, the bottom nav
changes, some of the tints on
drawables changes.  Think about
if your product manager comes to
you and says, we're changing all
the colors.  Wouldn't you rather
have this rather than going
through all the XMLs and where
is it?  You really want to limit
the changes to these semantic
names.
So, as a summary of this,
really, really, like, theme
attribute all the things
essentially.  Use them as just
kind of like protection and you
should probably push that
semantic system back upwards to
your designers so they are
giving you values that work with
this.
XML is the preferred syntax or
be careful when you're not
writing this and thinking, is
this a smell?  With your
drawables, think about using
tints to protect yourself.  If
all these drawables had been
pings instead and we had to
rebrand, am I going to have to
regenerate all of these?  Ignore
that, don't do that.  Use tints
instead.
Basically, if every time you use
a PNG, think, should this be a
PNG.  Pretty much the only time
you should be using PNG is for
matches.  So, that's a summary.
Protect yourselves and have fun
with attributes and styles.
Cheers.
[Applause]
Hi, everyone.  Today, I'm
going to be sharing some best
practices when using the
AndroidX library.  I'm going to
be taking about preferences and
shared preferences.  And I'm
going to cover how you can use
multiple setting screens.
First some background.  What are
preferences?  The preference
library is for interactive
screens. All you need to do is
find a list of settings to be
displayed to the user and it
also handles interacting with
the device storage so any value
the user changes would be
uploaded to the device.
First, the framework preference
API.  This has been bundled with
the first Android framework.
Since it is part of the
framework, any new features and
bug fixes we add only make their
way to the newer versions of
Android.  Given the design has
changed, the framework API is
themed differently depending on
which version of Android.  We're
no longer maintaining the
framework API and recommend
using the AndroidX library.  It
was the V7 and V14.  It with be
updated.  The library is
backwards compatible down to API
14 and uses the same updated
material theme.
This results in a consistent
experiences with your users.
How does it relate to shared
preferences, you can have key
data.  They are used internally
to save and retrieve any values
but aren't part of the library.
We'll load the simple hierarchy
on the right.  We have a
preference to
toggling and one for text.
So, we're going to start at the
top with a simple activity that
acts as a container this should
have an appcompat theme.  This
is the main entry point when
uses the preference library.
All the interesting preferences
and configuration will happen in
here.  This fragment, itself,
just wraps a hierarchy of
individual preferences, which
can be defined in an XML
resource or programatically in
runtime.  We're going to focus
on XML.
So, the activity, itself, is
just a simple container for our
fragment.  We have fragment
boilerplate and show the
fragment. The fragment, again,
fairly simple.  All you need to
do is overwrite this and set up
the hierarchy. The interesting
definition happens in the XML.
So, this is our XML file.  We
start with a root preference
screen object and this is the
main container for the
hierarchy.  Note that you should
also place your preference XML
in the XML directary.  This is a
basic preference, it doesn't
have any widget associated with
it and we have three important
attributes here.  The title and
summary are displayed to the
user.  The key is pretty
important.  If this preference
were to persist any state to the
device, then this is the key
that the shared preference would
use.  This key allows you to
interact with this preference
later on in the lifecycle.
Now we can add a switch
preference compat.  This is
similar to before, but now we
have a switch widget.  Whenever
the user toggles it, it will go
to the key defined here.
Here's the hierarchy we're going
to end up here.  We're going to
take is step-by-step.  I'm going
to cover categories to split up
complex groups and preferences
that open dialogues which allow
for more complex configuration.
I'm going to talk about dynamic
summaries and also cover
dependencies.
So, continuing from where we
left off before, these are the
same preferences we had before,
one of these controls syncing
some one displays static
information about the
application.  The more we add to
this hierarchy, the harder it's
going to be for the user to see
what does what.  We can set this
up in logical subsections.  We
wrap it with a preference
category tag.  It adds an
accented title above the groups.
It's important to set a key for
these so it will be a
correctly-persisted state.  Same
as before, same attribute, just
displayed slightly differently.
Next we're going to add an edit
text preference.  This
preference uses a dialogue to
allow persisting a string value
when a user taps on this
preference, we open a dialogue
for you which contains an
editable text field.  However,
this gives us some interesting
questions.  What do we set for
the summary here?  Right now,
there's no summary so it's quite
hard for the user to see what
the current state is and we'd
like to let the user see what
they've saved.
The answer here is to use simple
summary provider.  This is added
recently in the 1.1 alpha
release and it's part of a broad
category of things we call
dynamic summaries.  This simple
attribute, when set to true,
will mean the preference summary
will show the preference or the
text set.  We have a way for the
user to set a sync code and see
it automatically.  However, it
doesn't make sense for the user
to be able to change this field
if syncing isn't enabled.  We
can use a dependency here to fix
that.
Essentially, setting a
dependency allows another
preference to control the state
of this preference.  So, we set
the key of the switch prefance
compat.  Whenever the switch
prefance is turned off, it is
grayed out and can no longer be
interacted with.  When it is
turned on, it goes back to
normal.
Or hierarchy is almost complete.
Enable periodic syncing is on,
but what does that mean?  Have
we synced recently?  We can use
a custom dynamic summary to
display when we've lost sync,
providing more useful context.
Dynamic summaries are good if
you'd like to provide the user
with more context.  So, in this
case, we'd like to tell them
when we last synced their device
or when you want to display
dynamic
information.  This could be
version information or an
ID address.
We can use this to react or do a
summary from external state.  We
switch this.  When the
preference is checked, when
syncing enabled, we want to
display the last time we
successfully synced.  Otherwise,
we're going to say it's
disabled.  All we need to do now
is set this on the preference.
So, to do that, we call
find-preference.  And then we
just set the summary.  This
should be done in
oncreate.  The summary will be
updated based on the constraints
we've designed.
I'm going do use separate
hierarchies in separate screens.
A lot of times you'll want to
separate complex hierarchies in
separate screens.  If you're
already using the framework API,
there are some different ways
you have structured your
separate screens.  If you're
starting fresh, you may be
wondering what the best way of
handling this is.  We have our
activity at the top, which will
internally wrap a fragment,
which contains the hierarchy.
We can consider it to be a
screen of settings.  We have an
activity who loads a setting
screen.  This looks fine when we
have one screen.  What if our
hierarchy looks like this?  We
have links to other screens.
And messages will link to some
more specific messages
preferences.  How does this look
like with our architecture?
It's very simple to what we've
done previously with a single
screen.
The initial setting screen will
be compat with a hierarchy.  And
then the sync-scanning screen
will be fragment with a
hierarchy and so on for any
other screens you have.  All we
need to do is the final link
between the preference.  So
whenever the
user can load the screen.  And
they tap a preference, we're
going to swap out the screen
from underneath.
Because we're using preferences,
the initial settings
hierarchy is going to be as
we've done before.  We have two
preferences, one for syncing and
one for messages.
You may want to add an icon here
to provide more context to the
user.  This is just done by
defining a drawable with the
icon attribute.  So this will be
something like a drawable
directary.  So to do this, we
use the fragment attribute and
set the class name of the
fragment.
If your fragment is nested in a
class, you'll need to use a
dollar sign and that's it for
the hierarchy.
The activity is similar to
before.  We should implement
this preference.  This is called
when a user tapped on a
preference and allows you to
customize anything.  There is a
default implementation.
And the fragments are going to
be exactly the same as before.
Again, we overwrite oncreate
preferences and that's really it
now.  When they tap on the
message, the fragment will be
automatically displayed to the
user.
So, to wrap some things, we've
released 1.1 alpha 1, please, if
you haven't already, get it.
Please file any bugs on
issuetracker.Google.com.  We've
updated the Android settings
guide.  Please check it out for
further infermation on some of
the things I've talked about in
this talk and we're working on
template and public samples,
demonstrating this library,
coming soon.
For more information on Android
Jetpack, you can go to
developer.com/developer.
And, thank you for listening.
[Applause]
Everyone, our next session
will begin in just over 10
minutes.  Thank you.
Hey, my name is Cameron
Ketcham.  I work on the material
design components team and I
work out of the New York City.
I'm Gautham Sajith and I'm
based in San Francisco.
We are going to talk about
Material Design components.  So,
quickly, what we're going to
discuss, a brief history of
Material Design, what Material
Theming is, using Material
Design components, the color
type and shape subsystems and
how to apply these subsystems,
as well as our release process
and a little bit about
contributing.  Quickly, just a
brief history, Material Design
was announced in 2014 and there
wasn't a Material Design
library.  At I/O, a year later,
Google announced the support
library, which helped bring a
lot of code for certain
componentcomponents, including
navigation drawer, but there
still wasn't that much.
This year, we announced Material
Theming to have a larger
engineering team behind it so
we're working on implementing a
lot of the components based on
the Material Design spec.
So Material Theming, what was
the original problem with
Material Design?  Well it was a
great initial version of a
design system.  It fell short
with the expression of brand.
So, here's an example of an
email app and it looks kind of
like every other app that use
Material Design and it's hard to
tell it's even an email app, in
my opinion.  Here's an example
of the kinds of things you can
do with Material Theming to make
your apps stand out and we're
going to get into those details
in a bit.
So, quickly, how does theming
work?  Basically, theming is a
system that we've designed to
help you create a unique design
for your app.  You need to
decide on fonts, colors, shapes,
et cetera and this is a Material
Design sketch plugin that can be
used, which can help you create
design ideas.  Take a look at
material.io for more information
on that tool.
These are material theming and
they all look quit different and
there's also a lot more of these
on material.io.
Cool, so now let's talk about
how to get started using the
material components library.
So, imagine this scenario, you
got this fairly-plain app and
your teammate asked you to
redesign it.  So, you may be
familiar with the support
library design package, the V 28
version and you can use this.
However, this is no longer being
updated so you should use the
AndroidX.  One thing to note,
you can't use the com.Android.
If you want to switch over to
AndroidX, there's a nice
refactor tool on the site
that'll help you refactor your
app.
And then the next thing you'll
need to do is use our material
themes that correspond to the
Appcompat themes.  It helps you
with default styles you can use
across all of our components.
If you use
appcompat.lite, you should have
all our attributes and component
styles.  If you use our
components without these
defined, you'll get an error at
runtime.  If they don't exist,
it will crash at runtime.  Use
our theme, it'll give you all
the attributes.  If you're not
quite ready to switch over to
our full theme, you want to get
the attributes, you can use the
bridge themes and what these
bridge themes do is provide you
all the attributes but they
don't give you any of the
default styles so you can opt in
to use our components one by
one.
If you're extending from a
bridge theme and you want to opt
in, you would define in your
theme and then all of your
bottom app bars would get the
component style.
So, now, we're just going to
talk a little bit about some new
components.  With Material
Theming, we introduced a few new
things, such as the bottom app
bar.  The bottom app bar
displays navigation and key
actions at the bottom of mobile
screens, which are great for
people who are one-handed, using
their thumb to interact with the
device.  It uses a coordinator
layout to coordinate the motion
between a bottom app bar and a
floating action button.
So, here, we just have simple
XML for the bottom map bar.  A
few of the things you can do is
set the vertical off-set and set
the fab cradle margin, which is
the distance between the fab and
the bottom app bar and the
rounded corner radius, which is
the corner where the bottom
meets the fab.  You can have the
bottom app bar hide on scroll
and set this alignment mode.  It
will animate the fab for you.
And it's useful if you're going
between different screens.
If you're already using a
toolbar, it's super easy to
start using the bottom app bar.
If you're setting the support
action bar, set it for the
bottom app bar instead and
everything else works the same
way.  You can use an on-menu
click listener directly on the
bottom app bar.
We also have what's revamped
version of the button to make
styling much simpler.  So, if
you just put this material
button component in your XML,
you'll get a styled button.  If
you're using our full theme, you
can use the button tag
in your XML and we do custom
view inflation where this will
inflate into a material button
tag and you can see the disabled
state on this button and all the
states will transfer over.  You
can set an icon on this button
by setting the icon attribute as
well as this icon style and this
style's optional, but what it'll
do is it'll adjust the padding
slightly to
achieve more balance on the
button.
You can set the outline button
to get the hairline button.  You
can set the background tint of
the button by sitting the
background tint attribute and
provide a color state list.
You can set some other
attributes, such as stroke
width, stroke color, corner
radius on this button.  You can
also create just an icon-only
button.  We're setting the icon
and setting the padding to zero
so the icon is centered in the
button and we set the content
description on this button.
Since there's no text, you
should set a
description.
You can set the ripple color on
the button.  If you set a purple
ripple on here and apply it to
the button, you can do a color
state list or hex color here.
It's a purple ripple, it's on
top of a green button.
And these are some of the
examples.  We have several
different styles of chips, text
fields, password show and hide
functionality and layouts, as
well.
Okay.  Now, a little bit about
theming.  MDC replies on the
theming of Android so here's a
quick refresher of how themes
and styles work.  Anything
applied directly to a view in
XML will only change the single
view.  You can also update the
style.  So, if you set an
attribute in a style, changing
this here will affect any fews
that are using this style.
If it's not to define a style or
there's no style set, it'll go
back to the default style.  So,
here, if you want to change the
way a whole group of components
look, you can set the default
style.  And then finally, if
that attribute isn't defined
anywhere else, it'll look in the
theme.  The way Material Theming
works is there's a set of
top-level attributes you should
overwrite for tipography,
colors, shapes and the default
styles.  If you need more
fine-grain control, you can hook
in, in any of these layers, and
change just the color of a
single view or the color of all
a certain component.
Here's an example from our
library of the chip.  It comes
from the fact that other styles,
in our library, can reference
these same attributes.  Here's
an example of a button.  They
have the same shape appearance,
which is the small component
shape appearance.  If we want to
update the look and feel of our
app for these small components,
all we have to do is update this
attribute in one place in our
theme and we'll show you an
example in a little bit.
What are the affects of these
attributes?  We try to apply
theme attributes in a way that
would make sense, but it's
definitely possible for you to
pick values for different colors
that may not look great
together.  You should check out
material.io to see how it'll
react.  Another simple solution
that you could do is to make a
debug theme which sets whacky
values and see how things look.
Here's the bottom map bar on the
material.io site and you can
see, there, that the container
itself is, like, a surface and
the icons are the on-surface.
And, we'll talk about which
attributes you can modify, as
well as things to look at for in
the next section.
So, theming subsystems.  We
currently have type, color and
shape.  These are the ones you
should tweak in order to theme
your app.  Hopefully most of you
are familiar with text
appearances.  But we've
incorporated Material Theming,
which using theme attributes, to
reference these text
appearances.  So, here's an
example of a toolbar, which uses
the headline six attribute
rather than a style directly.
And here are some copy that uses
the body one attribute.  These
are the type attributes that
we've defined so if you
overwrite any of these in your
theme, you can set the style and
look of your app.
Color's another one and you're
probably familiar with primary
color and primary accents.  We
have a wider range of colors so
you have more control.  These
are the semantic names of the
pallet of colors that work with
cullerative theming.  We have
primary, primary veryiants.
Those are the things you should
generally theme to be the stale
of your app.  There's also a
background surface and error
colors.  You can style those,
but you don't necessarily have
to.  And then the on-primary,
the on-secondary, those need to
be accessible when they're drawn
on top of the other colors.
On-primary, that will be drawn
on top of the primary color.  If
you have text shown on top of
the primary background, it
should be the on-primary color.
These are the color attributes
that we've defined.  You can see
that there's a lot of new ones.
We tried to reuse some that came
from appcompat and we have
Android color background that we
use, which is just the regular
Android version of that
attribute.
Shape is another subsystem that
you can theme.  And it all
happens with material shape
drawable.  So, we're adding
material shape drawable as the
background for buttons,
cards, fab, bottom map bar.  It
works with edge and corner
treatments.
We have edge and corner
treatments defined for rounded
and cut corner, which is every
component you're going to find.
You can always create your own,
as well.
So, here's an example of Kotlin
code, which defines a rounded
corner, treatment and sets that
to the material shape drawable,
to apply rounded corners to
everything.  Here is the XML
version, as well.  So, if you
want to do it in XML, we have
shape appearance and it's
similar to text appearance.  The
attributes, here, are the corner
family and the corner size and
this sets it to be a rounded
corner with 24Dd radius.  You
can overwrite individual
corners.  We are overwriting the
top left to be cut and you can
do the same thing in XML.  One
thing to notice is that we're
using a shape appearance overlay
here, which is basically the
same thing except for we only
define the attributes that we
want to override.  The material
button has a shape appearance
some here, we're setting the top
right corner to be cut.
Everything else will be
inherited from the style of the
material button.
One key
idea of Material Theming is to
add mapping.  This can help give
your app a more consistent look
and feel by connecting surfaces
through shape.  There's small,
medium and large components and
these are the attributes you can
set in your theme.  If you want
to restyle all the small
components to have a cut right
corner, you can do that.
Here's an example where, just
like I said, overriding the
small component style.  So, we
redefine the small appearance,
the small component shape
appearance, in the theme, to our
style.  And here, we're setting
the top-right corner to be cut
and we're also setting the
parent here so that will inherit
all of the other -- the rounded
corners for the other parts.
Shadow is something we want to
mention, as well.  Native
elevation is supported for
shapes on Lollipop.  For API 21
and up.  But we're back porting
shadows to API 15 for both
concave and convex shapes for
common cases, such as rounded or
cut corners, as well as for the
bottom map bar because this has
the cut-out inside of it.  It
won't get native shadow, so we
fake the shadow with a gradient.
Now that we've heard about our
theming subsystem, how do you
apply those to your app?  You
have this appcompat app, we'll
be building something that looks
a little bit like this.  When
you build your own apps, it will
look much more beautiful and
cohesive than this.  So, first
thing you'd have to do is, if
you're using action bar theme,
you can switch over to material
components theme.  We're using
the bridge theme because we want
to opt-in to using those one by
one.  Generally we recommend you
switch to the full theme, the
regular theme before trying out
the bridge theme.
So, let's say you set these
theme color attributes.  Some of
the existing ones you know are
primary and secondary.  There is
primary on-secondary.  You'll
see this color secondary doesn't
show up anywhere in your app
yet, but it will.
Next thing we want to do is get
material buttons.  If you set
the material button style in
your theme, all of your buttons
should turn into material
buttons when you change the XML
tag.  If you're using our full
theme, this happens
automatically.
We have a bunch of other default
styles we've laid out here, all
it's component name, plus style.
For example, if you would set
material card style in your
theme.  And then we're going to
be applying some attributes to
these cards.  You can sent card
elevation, stroke color and
stroke width.
And then say you wanted to
change the base style of all the
buttons, you would define your
own button style and set the
parents of it to outline button
and then all of your buttons
change into outline buttons.
We can now apply some shape
theming to all of your buttons.
So, we're going define the shape
appearance and set the right
corners to be cut and the left
corners to be rounded and set
the corner size and now you have
this arrow-shaped button.  You
can also do this using a shape
appearance overlay, since
buttons have a rounded corner by
default.  You don't have to set
it for the left side.  You deset
what you're changing and it'll
take effect as normal.
And then say we wanted to have
some icon buttons, you would
define this icon button style.
Set the paddings and minwidths
as you want and then apply this
to your button directly in the
XML, as well as setting that
icon in content description and
then you have the share icon
button instead of that share
text button.
You can also switch over to the
bottom map bar.  So for this,
you'd have to set it in your
theme and then remove the top
app bar from your XML layout and
add this bottom app bar here.
You can add a floating action
button by adding the floating
action button to your layout and
setting the layout anchor
attribute to point to the app
bar.  This fab has that teal
color and that's because we
haven't set the default floating
action button style yet.  So,
once that's set, you'll see it's
using color seg
secondary.
Then we can do some text styling
for the content of our cards.
Say you want all of your text to
be color on-surface, we're going
to be using a material theme
overlay, which I'll talk about
in just a second.  It sets the
theme for all the contents of
that components.  We're setting
it tertiary.  So material theme
overlay, you might have heard of
Android theme, you can style a
subsection.  You can style a
dark-colored toolbar in your
app.  The shortcoming is it
doesn't work in default style.
You can't set Android theme.
Material Theming attribute is
supported by our components and
it does work in default styles
so you can set this for your
components and have it theme --
the subviews of your components.
Lastly, we'll do some text
appearance theming.  So,
previously, the title was
hard-coded text appearance
style.  And similarly, for the
text -- note body, as well.
And then we can apply some
styling to this.  So, for
example, if you change headline
six to be comic sans, it should
now look like this.
So, why go through the trouble
of doing this?  Like, why go
through the trouble of using
top-level attributes for your
style?  Generally, we do this
because we want to be able to
style your entire app using
these top-level attributes.  Say
your teammate said, hey, our
brand colors are changing and we
want this maroon color instead
of these blues we have.  You
switch the top-color attributes
and your whole app is rethemed.
If you want a dark theme or fake
dark theme, you change the color
attributes and they should
respond appropriately to that.
Now we're going to talk about
custom components and how you
can use some of your styles.
There's really nothing magical
about the way our components use
theming.  It's all just basic
Android theming, so you can use
it in your components, as well.
You just have to create a
default style and pass it into
your constructer.  So, let's go
through that.  Here we have a
definition of a theme and some
attributes.  Here, we're
creating a default style
attribute and setting it in our
theme so we have my custom view
style and we're setting it to
this widget.mycustomview style.
So, this will mean that any
components that use this
mycustomview will use this style
by default.
You also can create a styleable,
which holds a few different
attributes.  And then you just
need to use these in the
constructer.  Here's an example
for a view.  Here, we pass in
the default style, which we
created previously.  And, we
pass this in here so that it can
pick up that default style if
nothing else is set.  And then,
raising attributes and pass in
the styleable that we just
created, as well as the one
passed into the constructer and
a fall-back style as a last
resort for finding attribute and
read those in.  That's basically
how our components work.  So,
you can definitely do it
yourself, as well.
And also, extend the systems for
your use cases.  Like, if you
have the need for more
attributes in some case, you can
definitely add those in.  It
might be a little bit more work
on your part because you'll have
to update styles for all of the
components you're using since
our components aren't going to
be referencing them.  But if you
need if, you can definitely do
that.
Here's an example.  Just like an
attribute.  Create it and define
it in your theme and reference
it in styles or elsewhere.
Now, a little bit about our
process.  We've had a few
releases.  The 1.0 went out --
was cut on July 20th and it's
been a little while.  But now
with the Android Jetpack re
refactor finish, we can release
more frequently so we're trying
to ramp up our releases and we
cut 1.1 alpha 1 October
31s t and we're trying to do
this more frequently.  There was
type theming, color theming and
dark theming, plus lots of bug
fixes and performance
improvements.
In the upcoming releases, there
will be shape theming.  1.1
alpha, the shape theming
subsystem exists, but none of
the components are actually
responding to those themed
attributes yet.  But with the
next release, it should.
We also updated some styling for
dialogues, bottom sheet, menus,
those sorts of things are all
coming.
As far as contribuing and filing
issues, GitHub is where it is.
Go on GitHub and you can take a
look at all our code.  It's open
source.  And also check -- you
can check GitHub for
instructions on how to submit
bug reports.  We're taking bug
reportess at
issuetracking.Google.  But,
we're looking at different ways
to make it more obviiously what
we're working on and trying to
integrate more with the
community.
And here's a few more resources.
Material.io site is great,
especially the Android section.
Definitely check us out on
Discord if you're interested in
chatting with us or are
interested in helping us have an
idea for anything.  Come and
chat with us.  We have a tag on
Stack Overflow, so if you have
questions about implementation,
you can ask something there,
we're watching that and we'll
respond.  And then we have a few
codelabs, you can find the link
to those codelabs on this GitHub
page.
And, that's pretty much it.
Thanks for coming.  We're going
to be available for questions
and answers at the break that's
happening now.
Thank you.
[Applause]
Hi, everyone.  My name is Ian
Lake.  I'm a developer on the
Android team.  And I work on
quite a few projects, but most
notably the Navigation
Architecture Component, as well
as fragments and the AndroidX
artifact and loaders.  And
today, I want to talk to you
about single activity, why, when
and how.  And really try to
share the best practices from
the Android treme and from the
Architecture Component team on
what actually is going on in
this world.  There's been a lot
of questions, way back, from
2014, 16 and even here in 2018,
so we're here, today, to kind of
talk over all of those wonderful
things that make up what are
activities.
Activities are really a
component ant, at the same level
of content providers, broadcast
receives and they are the
UI-facing pieces of your app.
So when the Android framework
goes to start your application
from a launch icon or an app
shortcut or what we see when
you're doing multi-window, those
are all activities, right?  So
they are the entry points into
apps.  When the user goes to
launch your app, they're
launching an activity.
And, we had a very interest
quote from Diane Hackborn back
in 2016, once we've gotten into
this entry point, we really
don't care how you organize the
flow inside.  This was 2016 and
I think it was controversial, I
guess, in 2016.  It had 77
comments on Google+, all right?
[Laughter]
A lot of people were very
enthusiastic about this post.
Well, what does it mean?  Well,
what I think it means is that
the framework shouldn't care.
The framework shouldn't care
about your application's
architecture.  It needs to
provide the hooks needed for the
Android framework to start your
application.  But, you should
probably care about the
architecture of your app and
that's why you're all here today
and I love having you here.
So, the biggest problem is that
you really don't know what
activity's actually going to do.
So, what's the default animation
for an activity?  It depends on
the version of Android, what
manufacturer you're on and what
themes the user has selected.
Right.  So, similarly, we had
property animations added in API
11 and they're much superior to
view animations.  And the thing
is, is that while these new
things become possible on new
versions of Android, they're not
always applied to everything and
things like activities, they
don't support property
animations, at all, even today.
And even if we were to add them,
in the next version of Android,
maybe the letter after P, we
wouldn't be able to backport
them because they're part of the
framework.
Thinking about all these things
it's like, well, okay, what
should an activity be used for?
Why do we even have activities?
They're useful as this entry
point and beyond that, you're in
your realm of what your app
needs to do and you don't
necessarily need to rely on
activities being the thing that
you have to work with.
So, let's take an example.
We're calling start activity and
we have to use activitycompat
because we want to do a shared
element transition.  We say, oh,
we want to have this one element
shared.  Well what do APIs work
on?  It depends on what you mean
by, work.  It launches an
activity, that's true.  It's
only going to do a share
transition on newer editions,
21+.  It technically works,
you're saving some API checks.
But really, this isn't the
prettiest code to look at.  Are
there any hidden gotchas?  If
you tested on an older version
of Android, are you actually
going to get the same
experience?  In this example, I
actually ran into this and I was
like, oh, things are fading in
and out.  You need to exclude
things like the status bar and
navigation bar, otherwise
they'll flicker and I was like,
well, okay, well that's fun.  I
wouldn't have ever known that
unless I tried it once and I
tried it on all a whole bunch of
have
of devices.  There are a lot of
hiten gotchas you can't control.
Another example where we have
different activities and it's
its own component.  If you have
two and you want to share data
between them, there isn't a
scope for that.  It is served by
services.  You want a shared
scope within a couple of
components.
So, this is the structure that
Android provides, but it's maybe
not the one you actually want to
use.  What you actually want is
you want to build the layering
you needs.  We can have multiple
destinations within an activity
and share information across
each of these destinations by
using the activity scope as an
actual useful element now.  So,
for example, you could have a
shared view element, a ViewModel
that both destinations talk to.
One destination could put data
in and one could observe changes
to that data.  You don't need to
work at the application scope
level for this to work.
So, I mentioned this word,
destination.  So, what is a
destination?  Well, really, it's
just a subsection of your UI.
So, for most destinations,
they're going to take over
the majority of your screen.
Right.
Like, when you move from screen
to the next screen in your app,
it's going to change the vast
majority of your screen.  Maybe
you have global navigation, like
a bottom nav.  The rest of this
is all in a destination.  So,
the subsection of your UI, we
have a word for this called a
fragment.  But a fragment's one
implementation of this idea of
having separate destinations for
each screen in your app.
And really, this fragment is
serving as the view controller,
right.  The thing that isn't a
view itself, but something that
owns and changes those views,
which are really more about
display.
All right.  So, really, the
activity, instead of owning all
of this business logic and
things like that, is really as
small as physically possible and
working on that shared UI that's
shared across all destinations.
So, when we're thinking about
this, like, if we're moving from
this activity world to a
destination world, we want to
make that world as easy as
possible, otherwise, why would
we move?  We focused on two
things.  One was the global UI
kind of thing.  Like, how can we
make that part easy?  It's
something that every app has the
same kind of patterns and we
don't want that to be something
that takes a lot of effort to
do.  Also, the navigating
between destinations, right.
Activity, activitycompat thing,
can we make that even easier?
We started the Navigation
Architecture Component and
reintroduced it to you all at
I/O.  It is still in alpha right
now and we're looking to fill
out all the feature gaps before
taking it to 1.0 here soon.
But really what this allows us
to do is take a super simple
activity like this, set content
view, we'll set an action bar
because that's a thing, right?
And, we want to make this smart
but we still want it to fit on
this one code slide.  So, some
of this is we need a nav
controller.  It knows how your
app works via a navigation
graph.  We can get one.  We're
using Kotlin here and call
findnavcontroller.  We're giving
it the ID of a nav host
fragment.  It is that part of
your UI that's going to change
when' ever you change
destinations.  We'll add an app
bar configuration.  This
controls the up action and what
needs to happen when you move up
from a destination.  And how do
we hook that up?  We have a nice
one-liner that says set up the
action bar, gives it a nav
controller and an app bar
configuration.
Now because we're using a drawer
layout here in our app bar
configuration, we also want to
open and shut the drawer when
you hit the button.  We'll call
navigate up in our support
navigate up.  We've set up our
whole action bar and now it
changes titles as our
destination changes.  We're
good.  If we want to add the
navigation view so we can click
on the side nav, that's one
line.  We can do this all
because the nav controller knows
about our destinations in our
app.
So, then how do we actually do
navigate actions if we're not
doing fancy one-liner stuff?  We
can get a nav controller from
anywhere.  It's even easier from
a fragment, we can do
findnavcontroller and we've
built a Kotlin extension for
this.  Any view that's created
by any fragment in your
navigation graph can call find.
So, you have this reference to
it from basically anywhere.
And, we really tried to think,
like, all right, well, if you
have arguments to something, how
do we make this nice?  So, we
built a Gradle plugin
.  We generate a directions
object, which has a nice, simple
show profile method, which gives
you a directions object with
typesafe arguments you define in
your navigation graph and then
you just call to navigate.
So, this makes it a lot easier
but we can go a lot farther with
navigation.  Has any one ever
built an intent filter before?
Deep-linking in your app?  Has
anyone enjoyed that experience?
[Laughter]
Great!  One person enjoyed that
experience.  This is what the
Android framework knows.  It
knows, I can parse an intent
filter and start an activity.
But in so often times, that's
not quite enough.  You need to
go a little bit farther.  So
what we've done, in navigation,
is for any one of your
fragments, any destination in
your graph, you can add a deep
link.  It's a simple one-liner
and you can add arguments right
here and we'll parse those out
for query parameters and give
them to you as arguments to your
destination.  Because no one
likes writing intent filters,
we'll generate the intent
filters for you.  We added this
to manifest merger to generate
that for you.
So, all this layering helps us
build nicer APIs.  But, it also
makes it easier to test your
application.  Right.  If you're
testing at the activity level,
all of a sudden, that means,
okay, well, how do I test, start
activity actually did the right
intent and we have to build
extra testing frameworks on top
of testing frameworks to mockup
these things.  If we're moving
into a single activity model, we
want to test all those things.
We want that to be easy to test.
So, rule number one for testing
things at the destination level
is, don't test at the
destination level.  It's really
the number one thing with
testing, right, is making things
nice and separate and extracting
some of that business logic out
of a destination and into
something you can test in
isolation.  Right.  So example,
a ViewModel is a great place
because you can test it in
isolation.  We have a ViewModel
providerprovider factory where
you can inject it and test it
separate from your UI.  But that
doesn't mean you don't want to
test any of your UI stuff at
all.  Right.
We have Espresso test for a
reason.  We want to make sure
all parts of our app work well
and are testable.
So, how can we do this?  So,
last -- this Monday, we released
fragment 1.1, the first alpha.
And with this became a new
artifact called fragment
testing, which is about six
years overdue.
[Laughter]
And it's really around being
able to test your AndroidX
fragments in isolation.  Right.
Separate from an activity.
Separate frem everything else
and being able to test and
verify that that fragment is
doing the right thing.  Super
useful for Epress so test.  Your
business lodge, separate.  Your
UI is still something that we
want to verify is correct.
Now, the nice part about this,
it's called fragment scenario
because it's built on activity
scenario, which is part of the
AndroidX testing team and the
testing team was instrumental in
getting fragments out there.
But the best part about this
whole scenario is that it works
both on instrumentation tests,
tests on your actual device and
on robo electric.  You get one
test framework that works on
both of these.  Really exciting
opportunity and something that
now you can test with fragments.
So, what does this look like?
Let's say we want to test our
profile fragment.  We did a fake
user ID here and we call launch
fragment in container.  That's
it.  This one line has both
created an empty activity, added
a fragment to it and waited for
it to be resumed and now it's
ready.  You can now use this
fragment.  If you want to call
onfragment and run some code and
say is the fragment in the right
state, great, you can do that.
Here, we're going to see if it
is what we think they are.  We
passed a user ID, we can use the
ARGs class and say, is the user
ID equal to the user ID we
passed in?  You can see, you can
run any logic, any method on
your fragment right from here or
we run Espresso  OE test.  When
we click the subscribe button,
does it change the text to
subscribed?  Does it do its
thing?  We can do this with that
one line of launch fragment in
container.
For Java users, it'll be
fragment scenario.  They make it
nicer for you guys.
But, you don't test a fragment
in isolation because, you know,
fragments do talk to other
fragments, right.  I work on
navigation, so there's that
other bit of testing how can we
test the links between different
destinations, between different
fragments?  The nice part, here,
that we have, because we're
using these higher-level
components, and not something
like activity, is we have a
mockable layer.  Right.  One of
the things that we found, which
building navigation is most
companies, once they got to a
certain point and they're like,
well, we should add testing.
They added navigator to mock out
the start activity calls.  That
layer is handled for you.  What
we can do, in our activities, is
just mock out that nav
controller and confirm that,
yes, you're calling the right
navigate calls.
Here, we have our profile
fragment again and it's getting
our user ID and what we want to
test is this on view subscribers
button.  We click this and it's
doing something complicated in
the fragment.  How are we going
to test this?  It's calling
navigate.  How can we make sure
this is actually doing what we
want it to do?  Well, it's
pretty easy.  We can do our
scenario thing just the same,
launch fragment.  And now we can
mock out our nav controller and
now you call onfragment and what
we're doing here is actually
just creating our own nav
controller.  Like, there's no
nav host here.  But we can just
inject one.  This is what nav
host fragment is doing under the
covers.  It's calling set nav
controller on a view.  Now what
we've done is from this
fragments point of view, it has
a navigation controller.  All
those nav controller calls that
normally you'd have to inject
something, now it just works.
They're in there.  And now we
can just run Espresso tests and
click on the subscribers view
button.  We can use them also in
our tests.  And because they
implement equals, we can just do
a simple verify and say, verify.
Did you actually navigate to
where we think you're
navigating?  Even if there's a
lot of parameters in there, we
can now just verify and this
makes it so much easier to test
those interconnections between
each destination.
So, nav
controller's kind of a special
thing.  So many other things
aren't a service locator kind of
pattern.  We need to inject in
those dependancies and this is
another one of those, like, six
years too late kind of a thing.
But, we're finally working on
it.
So, there's a class in Android P
called app component factors
that allows you to construct
activity all via dependency
injection.  You get a chance of
caller the constructer instead
of the system calling it.  Same
thing here with fragments.  Now
you can do conSTRUTH
structer into fragments.  You
can use a fragment factory.
So, this is really useful, also,
for cases where your fragment
was, like, casting your activity
to something.  I know we
probably still have a template
that does this.  We'll fix that.
And, there's a lot of ways where
really want to inject in all of
those external dependancies so
we can test in isolation and
fragment works great with our
fragment scenario.
We know how to test a ViewModel,
right.  It's just an object, it
has a real method called
subscribe.  Really, we want to
test our fragment.  And our
fragment has an onsubscribe
fragment and it does its thing.
How do we get this ViewModel?
Well, we can inject the factory
itself, inject the ViewModel
factory.  Here we're using the
by ViewModels, a property that
does all that ViewModel
providers of kind of stuff for
you.
But, we now have a fragment that
we've injected something, but
then we still need to test,
like, okay, did it actually call
subscribe?
So, we can build a navigation
activity.  This is what it's
going to look like in real life.
Right.  We're going to inject
our ViewModel factory and then
because code is hard and I
wanted to write things on
slides, I built a helper class
call initializer and you call
add initializer for each
fragment and we call that method
to construct.  So, a little bit
of magic.  There's a link here
if you want to check it out.
We're looking at trying to
integrate this more deeply into
the library.
Once you've called this fragment
factory, it creates a profile
fragment.  It's going to use
this constructer and pass in our
ViewModel factory.  Great.  So,
our activity looks fine.  But,
our tests, how does that look?
We create a mock of our profile
ViewModel and then we can set up
a factory for it and then again,
kind of use a fragment factory
here that, again, does the same
type of thing where we're
passing in our mock ViewModel
factry and our scenario looks
the same.  We add it in and
instead of just the argurements,
also the fragment factory.
Now we can do our same thing on
view, perform the click and then
verify that, yes, our mocked
ViewModel did the subscribe
call.  We have a testable
fragment, a testable ViewModel.
We have a testable thing.
Now, we are looking at some
improvements to this API
because, you know, we want to
make this even easier.  So, in
this case, because we know your
constructing a profile fragment,
we want to change this into
something that looks like this.
Where you can say launch and
then give it a method saying,
oh, like, you launched this
fragment and specifically give
it the constructed-out instance
of your fragment so you don't
have to actually know that it's
using a fragment factory on
under the hood.
There are a few cases where you
might think, oh, man, maybe I do
need multiple activities.  And,
there's got to be reasons to use
multiple activities besides just
momentum.  Right.  I understand
that a lot of apps, if you have
multiple activities right now,
this isn't actually an easy
sell.  Right.  So, there are a
few cases where even, today, we
do recommend using multiple
activities.  Not a lot though.
So, what I'd like to say is, you
don't actually need multiple
activities.  What you need are
multiple tasks.  So, what are
tasks?  Tasks are actually the
thing that users are actually
interacting with.  So, a task is
a stack of activities and each
task has a backstack.  So, in
your overview menu here, each
one of these entries isn't just
an activity.  It's actually a
whole task stack, right.  So
you're only just seeing the top
most activity of that stack.  So
each element here is a stack.
Right.  When you're doing
split-screen multi-window,
that's two tasks side-by-side.
Right.  On Chrome OS devices,
things that support floating
multi-window, each one of these
tasks is a window.  One to one
between windows and tasks.  Not
activities ties and windows,
tasks and windows.
So, launching a new task on one
of these Chrome OS devices gives
you a new window.  Right.  So,
your app, maybe it doesn't need
multiple activities, but maybe
it wants multiple windows.
Right.  So, this is the case
where, yes, you need to use
activities under the hood, each
one of these tasks is going to
be a separate activity.  But,
you may not use some of the
other things, such as a stack of
activities in one task.  So,
what does this actually look
like?  A lot of this is that
there are a lot of different
ways of saying new task.  Right.
Has anyone looked at all those
wonderful launch mode flags and
all that fun?  Yeah.  How many
people of you are still sane?
Okay.  Well, I'll say that there
were a lot of good flags out
there, in Android 1.
[Laughter]
They were great back in Android
1.  In today, in 2018, they're
maybe not the best thing to use.
What you actually want to use is
document launch mode.  Document
launch mode was added, actually,
in API 21.  If you're thinking
about pre-API 21 first, what are
you doing?  And, second,
probably try and steer aware
from hackie solutions.  Maybe
it's just not worth it for those
users.  But try and avoid things
like launch mode flags and task
affinity and those types of
things because while the
framework does honor those, it
maybe doesn't honor them in the
way you want them to honor it.
There's certainly very different
types of thing.  With document
launch mode, there's
multi-tasking, if you can have
multiple tasks, you can multiple
windows.  You have multiple
entries in your overview screen.
So the first way of doing
multi-tasking is into existing.
Into existing means whenever I
launch this activity, that
activity has its own task.
Every time you launch this
activity, it has its own task.
But if we have already launched
that task, don't create a second
and a third copy.  This is good
for documents, conversations and
things someone might want to
side-by-side compare.  They're
not going to exit out of one
doc, open another one and copy
it there.  It's taking the
multi-tasking model that is
Android and making it so your
app actually gets to use this.
Now of course, the into existing
assumes you have some notion of
uniqueness.  It does assume from
an intent fitter equals point of
view, if you're using the data
UI on your activity, that there
is some sort of unique ID, a
conversation ID, a document ID,
something to uniquely-define
that task.
One great example is Google
Docs.  It launches it in another
task.  You can load them up,
side-by-side on a phone.  Two
different windows on a Chrome OS
device.  And it just works.
Even though it's one app, it can
have multiple windows and really
allow a different level of
multi-tasking between different
things.
So another big one is creating
new content.  So new content's a
little different because there's
not really any unique ID but you
want that multi-tasking behavior
are you can reference existing
material while you're creating
something new.  The always flag
is similar to into existing, but
it always creates something new.
It's like self-descriptive
names.  We can do this, guys.
It allows you to do multiple
things at one.  One example is
Gmail, it uses this kind of mode
when you create a new email.
This allows you to create a new
email and reference your
existing email at the same time.
It's magic, right?  This is the
equivalents, on mobile, of when
you do it on a web and it pops
up a little mole that's separate
from the other one.  You still
need that other material as
reference.
On a phone or an a tablet, it
looks slightly different.  The
other case is
picture-in-picture, it has two
entirely separate modes.  One is
using a separate task.  Right.
So, this would be a separate
activity, just for your
playback.  So, this is really
common on Android TV.  TV uses
this approach so you can
actually put things into
picture-in-picture mode and
browse through other movies.
So, in this mode, it's very much
that you have a specific
picture-in picture button in
your UI.  The other mode is
using just a single task, one
activity.  You don't need
anything at all.  This is Duo
and Google Maps where your whole
task is becoming the
picture-in-picture activity.
Right.  So, when would you want
to choose one or the other?
It's really this case where once
I'm in picture-in-picture mode,
if they were to click my
launcher icon, what would
happen?  Because the launcher
icon always launches the default
task of your app.  So, in Duo's
case, where they only have one
task, when you launch that Duo
from your launcher icon, it's
just going to pop open the
picture-in-picture.  Because it
doesn't make sense to have
multiple conversations going at
the same time.  You're never
going to replace one with the
other.  You're never going to
continue to reference something
even though something is already
going.  That's kind of the
differentiator here.  Do you
want to browse
picture-in-picture that the same
time.  If you do want to, yes,
you're using the Android
framework and they need to
position those separately.
Separate tasks.  Separate
activitiesactivities.
But, that's kind of it.  The one
thing I didn't mention are
things like instant apps.
Instant apps kind of works at
the activity level.  Right.  You
call start-activity.  But
there's actually some really
exciting things that are being
worked on by the Play team.  I
think there was a talk here at
Android Dev Summit.  A lot of it
is around the instance
experience for your App Bundle,
making your whole app instant
and also dynamic feature
modules.  These are really
interesting ways of adding
things on to the thing, that
don't require a specific app
architecture to implement.  We
can actually do more things with
this.
For the instant experience, it's
added
equals means true.  They can try
your entire app, your entire
base module totally instant and
this works really well with
things like app links.
So those deep links that I said
you could add to any
destination, you can also make
them into app links by adding
the auto verify equals true.
When someone launches your deep
link on the web, they're going
to open up your instant app
experience and download that
whole base module for you and
your whole navigation graph is
already there, ready to go.
But, this doesants work if your
app is too large so you want to
dynamically deliver things that
are not used very often or
rather big things.  That's what
dynamic feature modules are all
about.
About being able to download
them on-demand.  The interesting
thing about dynamic feature
modules is you're adding
classes.  You don't need to add
activities. You can add just
destinations, just the number of
fragments.  In this case, you
can add new destinations,
on-demand.  Just because you've
built out an XML file, each one
of these dynamic feature modules
can add their own navigation
graph.  So, this means that
we're not tied to separate
activities.  We can now actually
still use one activity.
Now, there's still more to be
done here, both on the Play side
and on the navigation side.  But
we want to make this really easy
for developers to use.  So, what
we want to get to is where you
can add something to your
navigation graph with a feature
tag, just like you'd add a
fragment tag and when you
navigate to this destination,
that's actually going to do all
of the downloading and making
your feature module available
from whatever your split name
is.  So, that's the world we
want to get into where you can
use a single activity.  Where
you can use a lot of the useful
things, like deep-linking in
navigation, without contorting
your app architecture.
So, I'd really like to end this
with one note.  A lot of you
have existing apps that have
very different kind of
experiences and I'd like to say,
do what's right for your app.  I
think single activity's great.
I was writing a new activity, it
would also be single activity
but I
realize that doing and saying,
hey, let's rip the whole app
apart, is sometimes a hard sell.
Some of them don't like your
current app.  So maybe you'll
actually get some, yeah, okay,
good for it.  Really depends on
your own experiencement if you
find yourself contorting your
own experience and it's not
making sense to you, don't do
it.
Right.  If something is working,
that's good.  Keep it working.
Right.  But if you're finding
you're running into issues,
you're having inconsistent
behavior or you want to do share
ViewModel, maybe that's the time
to think about moving toward a
single activity.
Thank you. Q&A outside. Really
appreciate you all coming.
[Applause]
Everyone, the next session, in
this room, will begin in 10
minutes.  Thank you.
[Applause]
Hello.  And, welcome to the
last session of Android Dev
Summit, over the ultimate, I
think.  The is called Get
Animated.  I'm Nick Butcher.
I'm Doris Liu.  I'm
responsible for Android API.
I'm
Nicolas Roard.
John Hoford, working on
MotionLayout, and design tools.
Great.  So, let's get started.
So, Android has always had
animation APIs.  The number of
APIs has grown as the system has
grown and become kind of more
fully-featured.  There are a
variety of different APIs for
different situations that have
been added over the different
API releases, as well as to the
new support libraries, like
AndroidX.
But, sometimes, we hear that the
variety, the range of animation
systems can be overwhelming.
That you don't know which one to
reach for or which is the best
for a certain use case.  So
our goal is to give you an
overview, tell you what they're
good for, what they might not be
good for and give you there
confidence for what to reach
for.  We're going to spend more
time on MotionLayout, as well.
First up is Android's oldest and
original animation API, which is
Android view animation.  I would
urge you to consider it
deprecated.  It's not actually
deprecatedeprecated.  But maybe
just think of it in that way.
So, this, like, I say, an older
animation API, was kind of --
runs in a certain phase of the
system.  Most views have a
measure layout and a draw.
Because the animations only run
in the draw pass, it means that
we can't do certain things like
deferring a rendering when we
don't need it.  It also leads to
certain things to where because
only the animation is only
applied the draw pass, maybe
you've animated a button, the
views haven't challenge.  They
only exist with the viewing draw
system basically, consider it
deprecateddeprecated.  It
belongs in a MUSEUM.
[Laughter]
I'd say deprecated except there
is one single use case and that
is when you're doing window
animations. When a new activity
launches, this API only accepts
this type of window animation
because it existed from API 1.
But also because these window
animations have to state all the
information to perform the
animation.  The fact that runs
in the draw pass is useful.
That allows it to define certain
things like, here, we're seeing
a wide animation, 10% of the y
position.  Because it's
guaranteed to be measured, this
can be useful.
The only other place is when
you're doing fragment
transactions.  You can supply
this Android view animation.
But the app accepts the newer
Android animator so I urge you
to use the newer one if you can.
So, that was view animations,
basically only really use it for
wind oanimations or if you need
to rely on that part.
Otherwise, think it's
deprecated.
Next up.  Animator.
All right.  Didn't change.
Oops. All right.  So, Nick has
talked about view animation, now
let's take a look at the new
animator that was introduced in
API 11.  So, the new animator
API's is much more versatile
because it allows you to animate
more than view property.  You
can even animate any value, not
necessarily associated with any
property at all, using the value
animator API.
And since the introduction of
animator, we've built a bunch of
higher-level animator
constructs, such as animator
drawable, transition and the
default item animator in
RecyclerView.
People always ask me, between
animation and animator, which
animation API should I use?  And
the answer is, definitely the
animator API.  Because it's just
much more capable.  And in this
section, we're going to look at
a few animators.  We're going to
look at value animators and
object animator, which not only
animates the value, but can
assess that value.  We're going
to look at animator set.  And
then, we're also going to take a
look at the view property
animator.  It is not an
animator, but backed by a value
animator.  We'll talk a little
bit more about that in a minute.
And then, also, we're going to
look at property values holder,
which you can use in conjunction
with value animator.  Here's an
interesting animation with a
juggling man.  That can be
achieved with the animator
drawable, which Nick will talk
about in the next section.  But
now let's look past that and on
top of this little man, there
are texts being animated in and
out.  So, in order to achieve
that, we can simply create an
object animator to animator.
The alpha property of this view,
pretty straightforward.  I'm
supplying an alpha string and
that is a bad idea because when
a property string is being
passed to the object animator,
we have to prefix that string
with a set and get to use
reflection to find the setter
and getter in the target
object's class and that's more
costly.  What we recommend,
instead, is using this property
object.  It is introduced in API
14.  Along with a bunch of other
properties.  What happens is
whenever the animation value
gets updated, the set value will
be called and from there, the
set alpha will be called on the
view.  Must more efficient than
reflection.
If we take a closer look at this
animation, we can see that the
text blows up, so there are
three properties being animated.
The alpha scale X and scale y.
Here's how we can do that.  We
can create three property value
holders, one for each property
and then we can specify the
start value and end value and
once we have all these property
value holders defined, we can
set this on the object animator.
Then the object animator can
drive the change of the property
values.
One caveat is when you use
multiple property value holders
on one object animator, you are
essentially animating all these
properties with the same in
turpulator, using the same
duration on the same object.  A
lot of times, we want to animate
scale X and scale y
simultaneously, that's what you
need.  If you want to define
that in XML with the property
values holder, it looks pretty
straightforward.
If you take a look at the bottom
of this animation, there's a
button fading in.  To coordinate
these different animations
together, we can create an
animator set and then with the
-- with the Play method, it
would return a building and we
want to play the fade-in after
the fade-out.  So -- and then,
while the text is fitting in, we
also want to blow it up so we're
going to play the fade-in with
the scale animation and then we
want to play all the text
animations before the button
fades in.
So, that's pretty
straightforward API and
powerful, too.
Now we've seen how we can
animate different properties
unconjunction with object
animator.  If they happen to be
view properties, you can call
this to create a view property
animator and then there are a
bunch of methods for various
properties and then you set an
end value and optionly, you can
set an in turpulator and stop.
It doesn't get more beautiful
and concise than this.
View property is backed by a
value animator.  It's not an
animator so you can't really
coordinate with the other types
of animators.  You can't reverse
it or repeat it.  Some people --
some people ask me, is view
property animator as efficient
as object animator?  I can
assure you, it's actually
slightly more efficient than
object animator.  The reason for
that, is view property animator
has been optimized for animating
view properties and it ensures
that for all the view propties,
there's one pass of validation
gets triggered.  Whereas if you
use object animator to animate
various properties, each
property change is going to
trigger its own set of
validation pass.
View property animator is more
for fire and forget kind of use
case where you start animation
and just forget about it.
Now, you might have seen this
animation before, in the
previous slides.  Did you notice
there's three little dots
animating at the end of the
text?  And these little dots are
not really a property for the
text view.  So, here, we're
going to create a value animator
to animate the number of dots.
We're going to type an
integer-type.  There's a repeat
count.  And with value animator,
you almost always want to use an
update listener because value
animator is going to animate on
its own.  So, here, with value
-- with the update listener,
we're going to read the value
out of the value animator and
use it as the number of dots we
want to show.
And then we're going to have a
spanable string from the text
view.  We're going to set a span
for the -- we're going to set a
transparent color span on --
rather on the dots that
shouldn't be showing.  And --
which with each animation
update, we will update the
number of dots that should be
showing and then
correspondingly, change the
range to hide the dots that we
want to not show.
So, to recap, when should we use
what kind of animator?  Object
animator is kind of this
all-purpose animator that, as
long as you have a property you
want to animate, you can use
that.  Value animator is for
animating a more customized kind
of animation where you want to
animate this value and then use
that value to apply it to
something else in your UI.  View
property animator is the best
use when you have multiple view
properties that you need to
animate simultaneously on the
same view and because you can't
really coordinate this view
property animator with anything
else, it's only good it for the
fire and forget use case.
And then property values
holders, with property values
holder, you can define multiple
properties and make them using
an object animator.  The nice
thing about property values
holder is that it not only
allows you to animate multiple
properties simultaneously
because it's really being set on
the object animator, you can
then coordinate that or seek or
reverse, so it's more powerful.
Animator set, you have multiple
animations you want to
coordinate, animator set would
be a good choice.
Thank you very much.  Next up,
we have animated vector
drawable.  These are great for
doing graphic animations like
the wonderful icons you see in
the Google Fit appplication.  It
basically connects together a
vector drawable to one or
multiple object animators and
runs animations on them.  It has
a very kind of small focused
API, it basically implements the
animator.  You can get a
drawable like this and call
start.  It is great for, like,
performance critical and vector
graphic information, especially
where drawable was reimplemented
in code.  Even if you're doing
the UI thread, it will keep
playing.  There is more time for
you to do your code rather than
running the animation code.
When you need to animate icons
or animate graphics, when it
needs to be this fire and
forget.  You can't seek through
it.  You can't control the
progress for it.  I urge you to
look at Kirye drawable.  It is
good for anything that's
performance critical.
Now, physics animation.  Who
doesn't love physics?  It is
perfect for a highly-interactive
use case where you have lots of
gestures going on and you want
to carry on that momentum of
that gesture into a UI to create
this sense of continuity.
Because when they allow gestures
in flight, you could then
potentially interrupt the
existing ongoing animation.  I'm
sure you've seen animations
where you want the animation --
you want the view to move from
one location to the other and
then there's just some from the
users and the ending location
would have changed.  And in this
case, if you use physic space
animation, that would simply
change some physics force and
then as a result, the course
correction would be really
smooth.
So, here, I have an example of
this little bubble with my cat's
picture on it.  And it's in an
application overlay window so it
sits on top of other
applications.  And in this case,
that is the beautiful Timely
app.  My goal is, is I drag this
little bubble around.  When I
let go, it should rest on either
side of the screen and -- so to
achieve this, we obviously need
to start with a listener and use
velocity listener to track the
movement and track the positions
and in the subsequent events,
we'll need to calculate how much
your finger has moved since that
down event and update the
bubble's position accordingly
and then when there's an action
up, that's where the interesting
thing comes up.  We're going to
calculate the velocity and then
here, for simplification, for
the demo, we're just going to
say, when the velocity is
greater than zero, we're going
to move to the right side of the
screen.  Otherwise, left side.
Now that we have the final
position where we want the
bubble to rest on, we can create
a string animation.  That is a
custom property, which I will
explain in the next slide.
Before we start the animation,
we also want to set the start
velocity and this is critical to
ensure that that transition from
gesture to the animation is
seamless.
So, this is my custom property
and the whole point of this
custom property is really just
to associate the animation value
with the position of that
bubble.  Whenever the animation
value changes, we get this -- we
get this set value call.  We're
then going to set the animation
value on to the layout
params.X because it is animating
in an application overview
window and have window manager
update view layout to reflect
that change and similarly, in
get value, we're just going to
return the
layout params.X.
Thank you.  Next up is the
transitions API.  Now,
transitions are about looking at
two different layout states and
saying what has changed between
between them.  Really, you can
think of transitions as a
factory.  Awhile ago, I talked
about how it's great for doing
things like this, two different
constraint sets and using
transition manager.  I think
this is
better-solved MotionLayout.  I
wouldn't consider it is good for
that.
You call this and make changes
to the view hierarchy and magic
happens.  It looks at the two
different states of the UI,
works out what's changed,
creates an animator.  There's an
overlay where you can control
those transition.  What I love
about transitions is what it
does to the code base.  Here's a
change where I moved it out of
the view layer into transitions.
Sometimes it can look gnarly
like this.  Pre-draw listeners
and poking around to the view
hierarchy.  By moving it to
transitions, we move it to this
declarative architecture.  It is
composed with some of the
transitions in a more composable
manner.  Yet, you might have to
write some transitions youself.
But, that code ends up being
much more -- I don't know --
nicer to work with and much more
focused and found it like a
really good change to the
codebase.
Transitions, which should you
use them?  For me, there's one
strong use case which is shared.
It's pretty much the only thing
you can use to achieve this
unless you go super custom.
There's actually two transitions
going on here.  There's the
shared element between the 2 AK
activities and then there's a
window content transition.  When
the window launches or exits,
run these animations on the
content.  When the viewer
arrives, the rest of the content
animates upwards.
So, when should you use
transition API?  Shared element
elements, for me.  Also, if you
are looking to modularize and
compose your animation code,
transitions can be helpful.  As
well as simple transitions,
using the begin delay method.
MotionLayouts.
All right.  So far we've been
talking about coding.  It's
super powerful.  The APIs are
really, really complete.  On 24
the other hand, it's quite
time-consuming.  What can we do
to help that?  We want to make
you more productive, let you
iterate faster.  We want to make
the motion design a lot more
accessible.  So one thing that
we introduced is the helpers
object.  And in fact, helpers
object is something that you've
been using.  We used for
guidelines.  Not really part of
your view, your hierarchy in the
sense that it doesn't show up on
screen but they are here to help
you create those layouts.  To
bring additional concepts to
make it easier.  In 2.0, we
exposed them so you can,
yourself, create helpers just by
narrating the class.  It's a way
of doing code and putting into a
helper, we support the user, so
it's easy to add and you can
think about it as a way of
tagging with a specific
behavior.  In the case of
animation, that's really nice
because, you know, you get the
code.  You have your helper
built and we have all the wealth
of the Android animation APIs
and you can do stuff like that.
Right.  For example, you know,
pretty well-known animation.
The only thing I really needed
to do here is define this piece
of code and really what I'm
talking about -- okay.  What --
what I only need to do here is
this code that you see on the
screen, I'm simply calling.  I'm
not reinventing the wheel here.
I'm not coming up with a new
way.  But that's the only thing
I need to do for my helper and
then in your layout file, you
only need to declare that helper
and specify the IDs of the
widgets you want to apply to.
So, it makes basically -- it's a
lot easier for you to package
blocks of usable code and, you
know, use them in your
application.
So, going back to the code
stuff.  So, the other way we
thought about making your life
easier, letting you build
reasonable bricks is by moving
to declarative way for
animation.  So, you can think
about it as a specification for
motion.  And, we interpret this
specification with a motion
engine and on top of that, we
are building a graphical motion
editor.  So, it's something we
introduced at Google I/O.  We
are still working on it.  We
decided to focus on the library
side.  Because kind of want to
make sure it's right for you and
for your needs.  But just a
quick overview on the current
build, it's coming along and
hopefully it will come soon, in
a version
of Studio.
So, that's kind of like the
overall approach we have for
helping you.  So, the helper on
one hand and this motion
specification on the other.
The thing that's kind of nice,
if I look at this, is that you
can specify this motion and
we'll then take care of it.  You
don't really have to write code
for it.
So, the one we implemented is
through MotionLayout.  So, what
is MotionLayout?  It's a view
group.  So, one caveat is that
it means you can only animate
the children of that view group
and it's a subclass.  If you
know ConstraintLayout, it's
great.  You can directly use
MotionLayout.  On the flip side,
you do have to use
ConstraintLayout.  But it does a
lot.  So, we do transitions,
properties, we have a really
good support for touch-driven
motion.  So it's kind of like
thinking values of animation and
packaging it into a single
place.
So, roughly-speaking, the only
thing you have to understand is
we are animating between two
states.  We have a start state
and an end state and we
interpret between those two
things.  So, in addition to
basically supporting layout
changes, essentially you have
two virg  versions of the
layout, we support custom
properties if you want to
animate color and key frames and
you can think about key frame as
a modifier on that, you know,
transformed between the start
and the end.
So, to kind of summarize, with
MotionLayouts, it tells you to
think about your animation, your
transition, your motion as a
declaration.  You just specify
what it should do and we take
care of it.  It specifically is
great when you want to do
fine-tuned animation.  So, it's
very specific what you want to
do, it's about coordinating
together in a very specific way
and finally, it's really nice,
as well, for the touch-driven
motion.
I don't think I need the mic.
So, I want to just kind of,
like, show you guys a lot of
things and be a little more
visual from here on in.  So,
this is the way you want to
create -- carefully
craft custom coordinated, crazy,
cool animation.  You can do
stuff like that.
[Laughter]
[Applause]
So, how did we do that?  It's
just two -- two chains.  The
change into one chain and each
letter's a view and we use a
stagger and a color change and a
custom match view.  It's fairly
simple to view.  It took me a
view minutes, it looks cool.
And that's kind of what this
stuff is all about.
So, the first thing, you can
drive stuff out with touch.  It
will handle swipes.  If you
flick, it'll go across quickly.
It understands velocity and
manages that.  The next thing to
understand is we're starting
from two constraint sets but we
have key frames and in this
case, here, I'm starting with
two constraint sets and I'm not
having any key frames and you
see how it crosses right there?
Right there, they overlap.  So
what you do is you add some key
position, key frames, and you
accelerate in the X -- you
finish the X part of the motion,
halfway through and that gives
you a kind of smooth, you know
-- you've seen this.  It's your
settings menu.
[Laughter]
So, the more extreme end of what
we can do with key frames are
key cycles and here, you can see
a bunch of different kind of
effects that we can do.
Essentially, anything that's
oscillating, it's shaking, it's
bouncing around, you don't want
to actually go and build out
complex paths with key frames.
This solves it.  In alpha 2, we
are introduing time cycles.
This is a crazy animation you
can do with it.  Of course, this
is way too over-the-top and
please don't use this in
product.
[Laughter]
But -- so, let's get into how to
use it.
Right.  So -- so, first of all,
there's information that we
created so I'm going to go
quickly.  Please look at those
articles.  There is also a
GitHub with examples.
One thing you may ask yourself
is, okay, this is great.  How do
you use this in my application?
There's an example where you
have a collapsible toolbar and
to this kind of things with the
normal collapsible toolbar, you
can simply use a MotionLayout
instead.  You don't really
change anything else in your
code, but collapsible becomes a
MotionLayout and take all the
advantages of it.
Similarly, you don't have to use
a new class, you can use
MotionLayout for it.  Same thing
for view page.  You can easily
plug MotionLayout into it.
The last example is interesting.
It's -- it really looks --
actually, this is pure
MotionLayout.  And what's nice
about it is that it actually is
too MotionLayouts nested and we
have one for collapsible to the
bar, it's the exact same one I
used before.  And it's simply
nested into a MotionLayout.
What's really nice is that in
order to specify this overall
screen, I just need to create
those two states, the start and
end.  You see that in the end, I
simply make the MotionLayout
that's for the toolbar smaller
and basically, we take care of
all of it.
So, to summarize for the current
state, we're working on the
graphical editor.  But for the
library, we did Google I/O and
we did an alpha 2.  And, you
know, even in alpha, it's built
on 1.1 so it's actually pretty
stable.  And in fact, because
it's pretty stable, quite a few
people started to build stuff
with it and we'll go through
some examples just to give you a
little taste of what you can do
with MotionLayout.
So, I looked on the Twitter a
lot.  I checked MotionLayout on
Twitter all the time and I
thought I would just share a few
interesting animations that
people have published.  Most of
these, you can actually find in
GitHubs.  These people publish
them as videos and show them.
This guy's been doing quite a
few pieces of work with it.
It's kind of interesting to see
what he did here.
And this one is particularly
interesting.  Basically, you
maybe notice in the previous
one, there was a motion.  Very
nice.  In this particular
example, what's nice is that
it's kind of like a view pager.
He added a way to drive it from
code and that's a very
interesting, you know, future
avenue for us.  It's a little
bit -- how can your code reuse
some this previously-defined
behavior?
So, another one by him, the
interesting thing here is it's
sort of mixing what is a normal
RecyclerView and then sort of a
reveal detail view.  But it's
interesting MotionLayout.
It is super easy to come up with
your own ways of doing these
kinds of transitions.
You're not limited anymore.
This guy implemented a material
design animation spec, but just
using MotionLayout and a custom
view that he built.  It was a
quite nice piece of work.
One of the things I liked about
this one is it's so original.
You see view pages.  Okay.  This
is taking a whole new twist on
it or spin on it, actually.
[Laughter]
But you can see, it's original.
You can sort of explore your own
creativity or your team's
createty with what they like and
what they do.
This one is interesting because
it's kind of like a typical
coordinator layout stuff.  You
see it's transparent and there's
special effects going on with
things fading.  It produces a
unique, you know, custom view of
the whole thing.
And this is our Chris Banes.
[Laughter]
And, he did a very interesting
one and it's a whole app.  All
the codes involved is out there.
It is very custom.  So, let's
take a closer look at it.
So, what's great with it is
this is the type of motion that
is purely by code.  There's a
lot of subtle coordination
across so many elements.  The
text is fading, that poster is
actually rotating,
but actually matching.  That's
what we mean when we are talking
about motion or fine-tuned
crafted motion.
This is the type of example that
we hope we encourage you to
build.
As a small sneak peek at what
we'll be having in alpha 3,
it'll support multiple states
and allow you to interact with
the multiple states purely from
touch.  So, this is one single
MotionLayout, but in fact, it's
handling transitions between
three transitions from a blank
page to swiping the bottom to
swiping a little bit, to swiping
more.  It's all one page, one
MotionLayout and it can produce
a fairly sphistticated custom
view.
This touch behavior, zero from
your end.  It's all
declarative.
[Applause and cheers]
Pretty awesome.  Cool.  So,
today, hopefully we've given you
a guided tour from animated API
and our goal was to make you
more familiar with what they're
good at and what they're not so
good at so I'm going to try to
summarize that as a takeaway.
The complex coordinated layout
and for that nice hand-off
between gesture and animation,
really do check out
MotionLayout.
If you need to build
interruptable animations or
gesture with the velocity
tracking, look at the physics
layout system.
If you need to do
shared transitions, transitions
is for you.
If you need to do vectors, do
vector drawable.
If you need to do window
animations, the original SDK 1
view animation system should be
used.
If you need to animate
properties of views, look at the
view property animator.
If you need to do, like, custom
view animation or driven by an
amimation
pulse, look at the animator.
Animator is your go-to default
for general purpose animation.
Next time you have to build
something, you won't be
paralyzed by choice of the
different animation APIs. So, I
thank you very much for joining
us and we'll be outside.  Thanks
very much.
[Applause]
Hello?  So, now it's time for
a completely different session
that will last about two minutes
long.  We're just closing out
the day here.  I was personally
curious whether you liked it or
not.  How many people liked the
dev summit?
[Applause]
How many people didn't like the
dev summit and what are you
doing here still, at the end of
the second day?
[Laughter]
So maybe it worked.  That would
be cool.  I think the people
from my team and Google liked
what happened.  A community
aspect hearing from you and
being able to communicate the
content.  Hopefully we will hold
this again.  Hopefully it'll be
a little less than three years
next time.  We have to convince
the people that write the checks
there Some of the favorite
things you saw this week?  Just
shout out?
Don't make it awkward.
MotionLayout all right.  What
else?  Preferences.  Nice.  All
right.  Yeah, new little bit of
thing coming out of the toolkit
area.  LiveData, yes.  Very
cool.  Low latency audio.  Yes
and live-coding C++ in a
five-minute lightning talk.  App
Bundles, yes.  Kotlin native.
All right.  Very interesting
coming online.
What else?  I heard paraside
chat, which doesn't -- fireside,
I heard of that one.  Actually,
that was really fun today.  Did
you like the chat?  Good.
Awesome.
There is everything available,
now, almost online already.  Day
one is already posted to
YouTube.  I heard earlier that
day two is going to be live as
early as 8:00 or
9:00 tonight.
Go back to your hotels or homes
and watch it.
Also, you will be getting a
survey, maybe it's in your inbox
right now.  Please do fill out.
We do actually read this stuff
and pay very close attention to
it.  Tell us what worked, tell
us what didn't and we will do
those things for you because you
are the reason that we're doing
this.
Let's see.  Anything else?  I
think that's about it.  I am
looking forward to doing another
one of these. Hopefully we'll
see you in 2021.
In the meantime --
[Laughter]
In case you missed everything
that happened, we tried to
capture it in 90 seconds.
Welcome to the 2018 Android
Dev Summit.  This is an event
for developers, by developers.
With over two billion devices,
three-quarters of a trillion
apps downloaded every year.
Android's developer community is
growing.
So, the Android App Bundle
makes it much simpler.  With no
additional developer work
needed, the App Bundle now makes
apps an average of 8% smaller to
download for devices.
We simply could not do this
without you, so thank you.
[Applause and cheers]
As Dave just said, thank you.
Thanks for coming.